Five,
four,
three,
two.
Hello,
nick and Joe,
sorry for the delay.
We had a a failure.
Ladies and gentlemen,
catastrophic failure of windows updating
it,
sort of a updated and hung on the
tricaster,
but we're back and it seems to be fine.
Everything's working.
Allegedly,
allegedly.
There's a,
there's that fear when you're like,
fuck,
I'm turning off the update.
I'm going to start again.
The unit is everything.
That is the one annoying thing.
We were talking about this before the
podcast.
I have been using windows to write on
and I like,
uh,
the thinkpad I really like.
I love the keyboard.
It's great to write on,
but windows updates like two or three
times a day sometimes.
Not just windows,
but like Lenovo will update and there's
some sort of firmware update and the
bios update and Adobe Acrobat checking
in and want to know if we can be
defender updates.
Yeah,
the uh,
I haven't used the thinkpad.
They got this little clip right in the
middle.
I don't use it.
I guess it's for people that have been
using it for ever.
It's very accurate if you do use it
right.
It's like one of those things where you
just sort of used to muscle memory.
You're used to doing it and then they
touch the other buttons with their
thumb.
Right.
Good.
They can still do shit and it has the
mouse at the keypad.
It has both.
It's so weird how quickly you become
accustomed to some new version of things
like I,
I've been using my ipad and I it and
then I've gone back to my computer and
my little Mac book and I find even that
weird like I find myself just wanting to
touch the screen.
I have my muscle memory is immediately
shot.
That's one thing that's very odd about
Mac computers.
They still have it embraced the
touchscreen laptop,
whereas the thinkpad acts has a touch
screen or you can straight up use this
screen on it.
Yeah.
It's an option.
Have one that has a touch screen and one
that does not,
but that's a lot of windows.
Computers have touchscreens and they
even have it so you can turn it into a
tablet.
You flipped it over and it.
I think they call it the yoga,
the thinkpad,
Yoga,
and then Microsoft has one the surface
or something like that.
Yeah.
Apple's like,
no,
we want to sell you two different
things.
That's exactly what it is.
We're not combining their dirty people.
They really are.
That fucking battery thing really pissed
me off.
Did it come out?
Did it finally get officially admitted
it?
Oh yeah.
They said they,
they admitted it and they said they did
it because the old phones,
they were trying to preserve the
battery.
The fuck you were.
You were trying to piss people off.
So they got a new phone.
Yeah,
we,
we all know exactly what it works on me
every year and a half for.
I'm like,
why does my phone fucking dying every 10
minutes?
And I'm like,
I gotta get a new phone,
dirty people,
dirty people.
I got the new one,
I got the new.
Uh,
the new is the,
uh,
the uh,
whatever the iphone asked Max.
It's too big.
I fucked up.
Is it too big?
I've never gone to the bigger one.
I've always gotten this,
this size.
Walmart.
It was perfect.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but I got greedy.
I want to go back.
They have some of those now.
The smaller like the four of the five,
that little size.
Why anyone was aware.
Someone had one the other day and I had
it in my hand.
I was like,
Ooh,
this is nice.
Yeah,
you can text with one hand.
exactly.
And I think they now make that one with
a higher power.
It's that size,
but it's.
And it fits in your hand square and that
the edges are hard.
Fits in there.
Perfect.
Yeah.
It's not like a slip.
This one feels like it's going to slip
out and you can't quite get around it
the whole time.
For one.
That one.
It also has a headphone Jack.
It's like the last of the Mohicans.
They got rid of all of it.
Oh No.
Yeah,
I guess it's still know the.
There's the converter.
I Dunno the Dongle.
Is that what it is?
They fucking,
they got me though.
I'm in,
I'm in.
I haven't used a non apple product and a
long time.
Well,
I gotta think like I was sad and I,
like I said,
and I also got the Samsung Galaxy note
nine,
the new one and it's very good.
Fucking phone's better.
Damn it.
I wish it wasn't.
Yeah,
man,
they figured it out.
They figured some shit out.
It's also just like if they figured out
the lifestyle of something where you're
like,
I'll take this branding.
I'm a creative,
I think.
Different.
Yeah.
Fuckers fucking work,
man.
I was like,
oh,
because I remember used to getting like
that apple,
the Mac book pro and be like,
I'm going to edit fucking.
I'm going to start editing mode.
Shit.
Well,
I remember hearing that Louis was
editing his show with a 13 inch Mac
book.
He edited his whole show.
Yeah,
and he liked doing it on the little Mac
book for some stranger on a plane or
doing whatever.
I get A.
I never edited anything I could never
fucking.
Do you ever do it?
Does your brain work that way?
There you good luck with a manual and
shit.
I feel like your brain works that way a
little bit.
No,
I mean I could,
I just don't have any desire.
It's like your brain has this at some
point decided like my,
I have a certain amount of capacity in
my brain and I don't want to use any of
that for anything that I don't,
I'm not interested in.
It's a good point and sometimes some
people like that stuff.
It's just like,
it's,
I've never been drawn to anything like
that and I'm just not interested.
Like as soon as I could have someone
else like do my taxes,
I was like,
Yup,
I don't want to think about that.
Yeah,
I don't want to do it.
It's all about bandwidth,
right?
Yeah.
Like what,
what are you spending your thinking on?
You could do all those other things,
but how much would that be?
Annoying.
Yeah.
And how much would it fuck up the things
that you liked to do and some people
love that stuff.
Like I have a buddy,
I have a buddy who's a successful actor
who still does his own taxes,
pays his right side,
his own residual checks.
He,
he fucking,
he likes it get.
You know what I mean?
I'm like,
all right,
well good for you.
Like in Judah.
That's joyful.
That brings you joy.
This doesn't have to worry about getting
ripped off.
That's.
I think that's part of it.
Chuck Palahniuk was here.
His agents stole all of his money.
No.
Yeah,
millions real that he's broke.
It's crazy.
How and what happened to the.
Is he going after the fuck it ain't
going to jail.
Yeah.
Fuck guys stole millions.
Stole millions from him and a bunch of
other people.
They don't know where the money is.
He's hoping to get some of it back.
They might be able to find some of it,
but the agents stole from several
different clients.
Although I just saw some madman and
chuck writes books about like,
watch out.
Yeah.
He writes books about creepy people.
Creepy Shit.
Someone did it to him.
Fuck yeah.
Dean's brother and his brother stole his
money,
right?
I think it's his half brother.
Half brother stole $7,000,000
and wouldn't tell anybody where it is
still.
Fuck you.
I'm going to jail.
Yeah.
And I think he might be out.
I think he might be out of jail.
Is He looking for new clients?
I think uh,
I think you like put it in coffee cans
and shit and drove across the country
and worried it holes.
Yeah.
I mean if you have a,
they will be able to find it if they got
a hold of your gps unit.
But if you got like a Garmin gps unit
that people use,
usually they go hiking.
You can need a mark where your campus
but you could,
you could do some low like Geo tagging
you shit.
You could totally do that.
You could go to the fucking woods and go
to a tree and dig a hole next to that
tree deep into the ground,
drop a coffee can with a million dollars
in it,
got a tag on it and come back to I keep
going to coffee.
Can,
I dunno.
Well there's something about.
Yeah,
there's something about a coffee can
that's very pleasing and the idea of
like rolls of money and like,
yeah.
And like chock full of nuts or whatever.
That coffee is like a folgers crystals.
Yeah.
He was probably garbage bags.
You know,
Fargo was just on the other day and it's
like,
Buscemi Haydn,
that money,
and then he like,
he's like,
he,
he takes it like he's got his window
scraper and he's in the far,
it's just like desolate snow for miles
and he just,
he sticks the,
like the window scraper into the snow to
mark where he's hitting the money and
it's like,
oh,
this guy's fucked.
He's never getting that money.
Like there's no horizon line.
It's just snow and fucking sky's groups.
You ever watched the new version of it
with billy?
Bob Thornton is good.
I heard it's great.
Season One's good.
Season two is I think for my money,
the best television,
like season two of that show is
unbelievable.
And season three is very good.
But season two is unfucking believable.
It's like in the seventies who's in it?
A Kirson Dunson it.
But like Jesse Plemons,
Kiersten,
dawn's,
uh,
who's the fucking,
I don't even remember,
but it's great.
It's great.
I like that.
I like all three seasons of that show,
but season two to me is like
unstoppable.
Are they still making it or are they
done?
They might go make some more in a few in
a year or two.
I think they might.
They were talking about making one.
I think Chris Rock might be attached to
do.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah,
I saw something like that.
I saw something like that,
but I don't know.
I don't know what the deal is with it,
but in season three is great,
but season two is fucking home cooks.
Half brother and sister
in law must repay $12 million.
Is this new list from 2010 when it
happened?
I got.
He got six years in jail in 16 years
probation.
So He'd be out by now.
So He's six years in the pokey in 2010.
Yeah.
He's.
I think he just got out dude,
because I remember seeing something
about $10,000,000
was stolen from him.
Fuck.
Must Repay.
Okay.
I don't have it.
Yeah.
What do you do?
How does that work for them in jail?
I mean the guy just stayed in jail,
like he could have a parent that's just.
I might be getting this wrong,
but I do remember some of the story was
that they were offering leniency if it
gave some of the money back.
It's like,
man,
fuck it,
man.
I'm not going to give it back.
Case like that,
much older cold.
What's that?
Some guy that found a bunch of gold,
he's in jail because he won't tell them
where it is and he knows people like
arguably hundreds of millions of dollars
or something like that because of how
much it's worth,
but he found the goal.
He like,
he found the golden.
Then he got investors to give him the
money to help them go to go retrieve it.
Oh,
he got it.
He was like,
ah,
I don't know where it is.
Oh,
is it like a shipwreck deal?
Yeah.
There's a lot of money in shipwrecks.
I was watching a documentary on these
billionaires are rich folks rather who
finance these guys to go hunting for
treasure.
There's.
They know where some Roman ships have
sunk and so they go looking for these
Spanish galleons and Roman ship filled
with gold coins that are worth hundreds
of millions of dollars and you know,
it's like this crazy gamble because the
ocean's fucking gigantic.
Yeah.
And also like,
I guess gold is gold maintain its
substance after it really does.
Yeah.
I guess why go earlier this grill of
shipwrecks?
17 billion.
$17.
Billion in gold.
They found it.
Yeah.
Some of the Massachusetts finds a
shipwreck with a treasure of up to,
oh my God.
Seventeen billion and so.
And someone financed it.
Icon.
No,
that's fucking wild man.
So,
um,
where is this fucking in Cape Cod?
God Damn.
300.
Ten year old ship Spanish ship.
Wow.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
There was a bunch of those.
I mean,
you imagine taking a fucking boat that
you made out of trees,
filling it up with them.
I try to float it across the fucking
ocean with like a map that some fucking
drunk dude had no knowledge at all about
storms come and like I hope we don't get
hit by one will fuck knows you've got a
farmer's Almanac that all the time I
just think about a letter.
I just think about like families like
immigrants coming over to this country
and like,
you know,
wherever fucking Ireland,
Poland,
Russia,
whatever you want to say like turn of
the 19th,
20th century,
whatever.
Hundreds of years ago.
People get over here and they're like,
I made it.
Okay.
I went to New York and now I'm in
Rochester.
Wherever the fuck I ended up and then
they have to send a letter that
hopefully goes back across the ocean and
then to like some fucking
mailman who's drunk and dies of a heart
attack in the mud in Poland.
And you're like,
you hope it gets to you to be like,
yeah,
okay.
I'll go meet you in Rochester.
Like I'm,
I'm blown away that anybody cotton in
touch with anybody and found their
family or what you would think you would
make a duplicate letters I guess,
so that,
that has to be a right.
They just were like,
I don't know if you've got the last one,
but heads up.
Um,
um,
you know,
maybe I'm a fucking slave in Rochester,
but I mean imagine the patience that
people have back then because like,
I'll get an email from someone and then
I'll get an email like an hour later.
Did you get that email?
Like Jesus Christ,
Bro,
relax.
That was just like I was,
I was recounting,
I saw a buddy of mine who I'd been,
I'd met and we were in Europe and we and
we met these kids in October fest.
They lived in Germany and we were like
meeting up with them in October fest and
this was before email and cell phones
and you just were like,
I'm going to be at the fucking to 10
train in Munich.
Like I hope you're there.
And that was it.
That was like,
you hoped that you connected and that
was that.
There was no like,
Hey,
I'm texting,
I'm five minutes late,
or like I'm emailing you to let you
know,
we'll meet at that Mcdonald's or
whatever the fuck it was.
It was crazy.
Yeah.
So it's amazing that anything got done.
That people met and got married,
had kids and yeah.
And then they traveled across the world
and then came back a month later and
found their family.
People were waiting for them.
Yeah.
And they did it.
It happened at time.
I mean,
and maybe it's shit didn't have,
I don't know.
I guess like you ever watch the show
vikings?
No,
it's a good show who,
one of the things that's crazy as these
motherfuckers would get on boats and
they'd go just row across the ocean,
kill a bunch of people and come back six
months later with some goals and
everybody be waiting for him at the
docks.
That's like,
what kind of life is this?
Yeah,
just waiting in the doctor's just like,
there's no version of like,
Fyi,
we'll be there.
Like,
it's not even like you're going to sit.
We'll just send the motorboat ahead to
like let everybody know that we're going
to be there in like a month.
That's it.
We're gonna.
People are gonna one day laugh at how
ridiculous it is to send a text message.
Like these guys weren't even telepathic.
Could you imagine they had a text each
other,
right?
They to send pictures because they
couldn't see what the other person was
actually seeing.
It's at all.
It's just going to be all in a fucking
contact lens.
Is that what's going to happen?
You just can't have a chip.
It's going to be a chip like Black
Mirror for sure.
Yeah.
How far off do you think?
Twenty Years Max?
Yeah.
I think it's going to happen so quick.
Just like cell phones happened so quick
that the iphone was only 11 years ago.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
And I pick the first iphone had a camp.
Did it have a camera on the first side,
but maybe it had something.
If you go back and look at your iphone
pictures from like five years ago,
how dare you.
How dare you accept this as a fucking
photo?
I bought an apple digital camera and it
was a giant hunk of shit.
It was like this big and it was one
megapixel.
It was fucking gigantic.
It was
so big.
Yeah,
it was just a brick.
I remember going and buying that first,
like a video camera early two thousands
to like put myself on tape in New York.
Oh,
you can hear the,
you can hear the.
And I would try to shoot myself to try
to get a,
you know,
there it is.
That's what I had was things.
And that's.
And is one second pixel and it was
probably like $2,000
probably.
Yeah.
And before that,
when I first came out here in 1994,
uh,
I had a meeting with this guy who was
like one of the big wigs at Disney and
he had a newton.
Do you remember?
It was like a tablet and he was all so
happy about this.
He had,
although very organized on is Newton.
He's like this fucking.
It was like a,
he had a thesaurus with a screen.
That's what it looked like,
this big stupid fucking thing.
And it had,
you know,
a little stylists and things on,
it was
in the years like between when jobs had
gotten fired and they were like,
or was he still there?
That was,
I think that was when the last years.
I just saw A.
Alan Alda just posted a thing on his old
Atari commercials.
I guess he was the spokesman for Atari
and uh,
tim talking about our,
you could also use for word processing.
And then also that they had like a very
early tablet.
He's like,
you can draw and paint on it.
And I was like,
shit,
that's bad man.
This is like 84.
Wow.
Which I'm like,
I don't know what that was,
but it was Atari,
early Atari Shit you could paint and
draw and.
Well they're the things that they can do
now.
There's these new.
Oh there's Alamogordo,
but loving it,
it was no big deal to use.
I love that voice computer.
Yet people new things.
Terry's going to a lot of trouble to
make it easier for you.
It comes with the phone.
Yeah.
No.
Well,
it's also funny because like back then
in the eighties,
like he looks young,
but he also sort of looks like how like
it was like he's 40.
Yeah.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
but he's probably not forties,
probably 30,
but he looks 40.
People used to a little bit older.
Yeah.
That's shit.
Nutrition and bad vitamins and the
doctors didn't know anything.
Yeah.
And like any sort of gray,
you don't know what it,
you know,
exercise well he's.
Although,
yeah,
those guys,
it is crazy.
It's also,
you look at old movies and you're like,
they're like,
it's an old old movies where you're like
cary grant or something.
You're like,
he's playing like the young bachelor and
he's like,
he looks like fucking 60 and maybe it's
60 or maybe it's just like he was just
fucking smoking and drinking and looked
like.
But he did not look good.
And you're like,
I'm still a bachelor.
Yeah,
there was no health back then.
No one was healthy.
No Man,
no one took yoga classes or wait.
No,
nobody's crossfit.
There was like,
I'm smoking
light cigarettes today.
We played,
uh,
some clips from I'm spartacus.
Oh yeah.
Douglas,
like,
like you think of him as like a Roman
soldier is like a guy who like probably
never worked out a day in his life.
No.
Yeah.
And he's holding,
this looks like plastic sore,
sore.
It looks so that you can tell he's still
just sort of like wanting to bring it
down.
Yeah.
Those old school bodies,
old school body weight lifters are like,
yeah,
he's not is just everything about them.
But I think he was 40 when they made
this movie.
I think we looked it up.
Yeah.
Did you think he was,
is he spoke again?
You never know how old?
How old is he supposed to be here?
Yeah.
You never know.
But he looks old.
Yeah.
He's got that dips below 60.
Look at his arm,
left hand corner that you look at that
now and you're like,
if the rockery made spark is right now,
it would look a little different.
Yeah.
Like look at this.
Well he's like thin from cigarettes.
Like that's the extent of a workout.
Slow everything.
I know,
I know.
Shit.
He used to be so,
but it gets.
People didn't care.
He's.
He's Tan though.
10 legs.
Yeah.
Because never done a squat and his
fucking life.
I don't know if they knew what squats
word didn't.
It isn't crazy.
Have you gone back and looked at like
what fitness?
Like the guys who were into fitness,
like what they were doing?
Yeah.
I mean I don't.
I'm,
I'm genuinely asking.
I'm like,
I don't know what they were doing for.
They were just like fucking eating eggs,
I'm assuming.
Well,
it was just very few of them.
There's bodybuilders back then,
but the numbers were so minuscule in
comparison to people today.
Like you can go to any gym today,
like you'd go to equinox and it's filled
with Jack people and women with giant
butts guys.
A big chest.
See that's all real shit.
That's a great workout right there.
Hanging from those bars and doing push.
They're still doing like they're doing
some circuit training shit right there.
Right.
But they're.
Yeah,
but they're.
These are like high school kids though.
Yeah.
This looks like.
They look very young.
That's all legit.
Yeah.
But how old were they?
There were 18.
There was no one who is 40.
Who is doing that?
No,
you go to the gym today.
You'll see guys who were in their
fifties were jacked.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
It's a different world.
And look at that.
That looks fun.
Hey Man,
I fucking love your show.
This show is hilarious.
Thanks man.
And that the character,
the animation looks like you.
It has your lips and your nose.
It's really weird.
It's like,
it looks like you without looking like
you.
You know what I'm saying?
They captured it.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's a.
someone posted.
It was right before the show came out
this year.
Someone was like,
someone posted like Japanese make we
make our cartoons a cuter Americans.
Let's make our characters ugly as
fucking possible.
And it's.
And it's mine.
It's me as it's me as a little kid.
And I was like,
I was like,
that's exactly what I look like because
it looks like you without looking like,
you know.
Yes.
There is a real gift to that.
When people,
they figured out how to capture the
perfect caricature.
It's weird that we and we give them,
even when we,
even if it's like we,
we try to,
like when we have new characters,
we'll just give them pictures of the
people that are playing them and just
let them find that version of them.
Uh,
and even when we don't,
we'll give people references because
there's something about capturing a real
person that makes it specific in a way
that you're like,
wow,
dude,
everybody can draw just like draw
whoever,
which does work,
but still there's something about like
being like now we want to guy,
it looks like Rogan.
Like they'll,
they'll get that essence that create
something that feels more real.
It's so weird,
but they're great.
We have a killer team of people
designing all those characters.
What I love about your show is,
well,
I like a lot of things about it,
but one of the things that I love about
is that you really can only do that on
Netflix.
It's just like there's,
it's so unharnessed yes.
It's just,
it's just wild and hilarious and there's
no boundaries to it.
That's one of the more amazing things
about something like Netflix is that
there's just,
you could do whatever,
you can do whatever.
You can do whatever length you want,
you can do,
you can say whatever you want,
uh,
you have no advertisers who you're
either supporting or in competition
with.
So we can mention brands.
They don't really care about that.
They don't care if there's no,
you know,
when you're a network tv,
it's like you got to get an act break,
you got the first act has to be eight
minutes,
second act has to be blah,
blah,
blah.
And even when there's,
there's more flexibility now,
but they,
but also most importantly,
they just basically let us do whatever
the fuck we want.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
They,
they've been very good partners
creatively,
if you just stand up special with them.
No.
I did one special years ago for comedy
central.
You just did.
You're just came out.
How was,
how was,
how was the experience?
It was,
what does the second one?
Well,
I've done three with them.
I did one with them in 2005 a long time
ago.
Way Back in the day and then I did one
two years ago in this.
They're fucking amazing.
You don't bother you at all?
No.
They just leave you on.
They go.
You're funny.
You want to do a special.
Yeah.
Okay,
go ahead.
Yeah.
That's kind of the thing and they're
just like,
you've proven that you can do your
thing.
We're not going to get in the way.
And I think they realize like,
oh,
we don't get in the way.
We just have less work to do and if they
find someone like you,
that is a funny guy,
they just,
they know you're going to try your best.
Yeah.
Like you're funny.
You're going to want to.
Generally it's not a money grab.
Yeah.
I mean it's like you want to go,
you want to go fucking do it and do it
well and you know that everybody's gonna
see it.
That's the thing with them right now is
you're like,
I don't know about you,
but it's like I just want,
if I'm going to spend a lot of time
making something,
I want the most amount of possible
eyeballs that I can get and that's what
they do.
Well,
especially for a comedy special,
there's really no other game in town.
I mean,
I've had friends that did something on
Hbo and I'm like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And if it doesn't,
if you don't see it that night,
right.
There's some streaming services.
I'm known as hbo go,
but I would love to see the numbers.
I'd be cured.
Many people are actually using those
things.
I would love to see the numbers across
the board,
but it is now.
It just feels like we were.
Because we went out,
we went out wide with the show.
We had a couple of different offers and
Netflix just seemed like the place where
it's like they work at a creatively fuck
with us and they were and everyone was
going to have a chance to see it and we
were going to get like kids,
like we're going to get anyone,
like we have like 13 year old,
12,
13 year old kids watching the show.
Whoa.
Which,
which is,
which is crazy.
Yeah.
Cause this fucking dirty.
It gets pretty dirty.
Yeah.
I'd love that.
The masturbation demon,
the hormone monster.
Is that your voice?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
that's fine.
My Andrew was like,
my partners on an Andrew Goldberg,
Mark Levin and Jen up were like,
they were talking about it because mark
and Jen have a kid who's was around that
age when we started doing it,
they were just talking about hormones
and all that shit and they're like,
we should have a hormone monster.
And then they were like,
yeah,
it should just be a hormone monster.
And then Andrew called me.
It was like we're thinking about doing
like a hormone monster and I just
immediately was just like you,
Sylvia,
Andrea,
and it just became.
It was like,
okay,
got it.
Alright,
we got him.
We got him fucking locked down and it
is.
I mean we have those.
We all have those things.
You know,
sometimes they get integrated,
sometimes they don't.
Well it's,
I just love that you just like what you
see in south park and what you see in a
bill burroughs show F is for family,
does things.
You can do an animated show that are
physically impossible in any other form.
And it's amazing.
Yeah.
It's an amazing format especially for.
I think for us,
like for if you're a.
especially if you're like a comedy brain
that doesn't necessarily come straight
out of like classic Sitcom writing,
that what you have other weird ways of
getting into something and you want to
be able to personify it and like
animation just allows you to do it.
It also allows you to fucking have a.
like you couldn't do live action stuff
with the kids,
with kids the way we have where you just
like,
it's just too uncomfortable but.
But you see it an animation and you can
get away,
be like,
all right,
let's have the statue of Liberty,
talk to that girl and let's have this
hormone monster and this season it would
be unethical if you had children,
actors.
I've ever worked with kid actors.
You a little bit.
Yeah.
I only did it once.
I did a show called hardball and there
was a little kid.
It was like a bat boy and the girl was
on the show and they were both like
early teens,
like 13,
14 and it was weird.
I felt weird because everyone else's
adults
and they would swear and say fucked up
thing.
You have to look over your shoulder so
you have the kids around.
Can you say something crazy?
I had to deal with a kid.
I was on the show called the league and
we had A.
I had a son on the show who was aged up
every year,
but by the last seasons,
four or five,
he was like,
from like seven to like nine and it was
crazy because we were doing some crazy
shit and there's a scene where he's like
eating ice chips out of a urinal,
urinal cookies or something like that.
It was like.
And it was fun.
It was a clean,
you know,
we made sure it was all good,
but still unlike we had him doing some
fucked up shit.
And you're like,
all right.
And the mom was there.
The mom was cool with all of it,
but it was like,
it wasn't just like even a sitcom or
it's like,
oh,
we're going to have a little,
maybe someone on set saying something
weird,
like we're adding this kid doing some
weird shit.
And it was like,
okay,
I hope this is all right.
What year did you get into show
business?
Uh,
how old was I?
Or like I was like 20.
I graduated,
started doing open mics,
like Oh,
two.
I was 23.
Twenty four.
Yeah,
that's good year.
That's a perfect year.
You're,
you're a young adult or young adult.
What about you?
I was 21.
Yeah.
Young adults.
Which I was like,
and it took a while to like get it all
rolling.
But it was,
it was.
I do think the early.
I mean I,
there are a few people who seem to start
young who were.
Okay.
Um,
but it's tough man.
I've never met one.
Yeah,
they're all crazy.
Have you met Seth Rogen at all?
Have you dealt with seth rogen with seth
when he.
He was on freaks and Geeks when he was
like 16.
Maybe.
That was the cutoff age.
That's the age where you could pull it
off.
Yeah,
because you have enough awkward,
uncomfortable.
Actual years.
Yeah.
Adult.
He also had like a few years on that
show and then that show got canceled and
he liked,
didn't have much of a,
like there were a few lean years.
They're good for you?
I think it made him a regular human
being because I'm trying to think.
There were no kids on newsradio right
there right now.
Were there any lifetime there?
Were there like a act?
They're.
No,
they're all,
all
adults.
All adults.
Except Andy Dick and just whatever he
is.
Yeah.
Have you had him on recent years?
Yeah,
I had,
um,
one once.
That's enough.
Yeah.
Random him at the comedy store the other
day.
He will not the other day.
He's not,
he's banned now.
Is he abandoned yet?
He uh,
he licked earl skakel his face and he
just,
he would,
there's drunk andy and when drunk
candies around you just gotta get the
fuck out of there,
you know,
you can tell the difference.
It's two different guys.
Very aggressive.
Gets like bags in the car window and
you're like,
oh no,
it's drunk candy.
Yeah.
And sober.
And he's a fucking sweetheart.
Wonderful Guy.
And so funny man,
he's a hilarious guy.
We,
we did scenes together where we had to
do the take five,
six times because I couldn't stay
straight.
I kept cracking you while your kids stay
straight with Andy.
But he is,
he is,
he's so funny.
But I had,
I did a,
I did a early.
One of my first things I did have like a
voice on American dad and I did.
They had me do Andy Dick and I was so
psyched to get a Gig.
You know what I mean?
I was like,
I'm not.
My favorite thing is not doing other
comedians.
Like there's some weird kind of code
that I don't know what.
Yeah.
And you know what I mean.
Did you feel like a Dick?
I try not to talk shit about comedian.
It just,
it's like,
I don't know why it's like I did it.
It was one of my first gigs.
It was like,
oh cool.
I got to be on American Dad.
I did Andy Dick.
It was looking back.
I would not probably do it now where you
know,
you just do it over the top.
I don't know,
I just didn't know what I mean.
Isn't andy kind of over the top as easy?
You know what I mean?
Like,
yeah,
I did not mean it was not been like I'm
going to go fucking get Andy Dick.
But anyway,
when I saw him,
when I.
Since then I've seen him over the years
and,
and I liked him and I think he,
when he's sober,
he's like,
you know,
I saw your impression of me and he's
like,
and he's kind of like,
it's funny,
you know,
and then I've seen him drunk and he's
like sow,
you know,
it's like a very different.
It's a very different version of it and
I'm like,
but you know,
but I get it,
man.
If someone did a fucking impression to
me on some animated show,
I dunno,
I probably,
I'm like,
no,
I'll do the impression of me.
I'll let me,
let me control my narrative here.
I think you gotta take your lumps,
I guess edition about you gotTa take
your lumps.
Yeah.
Well,
because then he's done it,
you know,
but he'd go back and watch stiller.
The stiller show.
He's funny as shit man.
Oh that was a great show.
People forgot about the stiller show.
That was a fucking great job.
Him Odin.
Kirk Janeane.
Garofalo Stiller Bunch.
I think appetite road out.
There was a crazy group.
What year was that?
That's midnight.
And or maybe earlier.
Ninety to 90,
it had to be pre news radio.
I think it was pre.
When does,
when does news radio?
Ninety four.
Did you come out here and get news?
Radio?
How old were you going to get news
radio?
20 seven something else.
I was on a show called hardball when I
was 26 and it was canceled.
It was a,
a baseball sitcoms.
Terrible baseball said,
come on Fox.
It's the one where I did with the little
kid.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But uh,
that,
that did like six episodes and they got
canceled and I was ready to move back to
New York.
I hated it out here.
But uh,
I got a lease on an apartment.
I had to stay here for a year.
Like I have this place.
I bought a couch,
I bought a TV.
Well I got a stereo goes,
man,
I remember how I got a stereo.
You like,
this is a six CD changer.
I'm not about to fucking move across the
country anywhere.
You remember that there was like,
oh,
you could put so many cds as fucking
thing.
You have people over and we'd go random.
Anya do random felt like a boss.
Then there were people
that had like hundred CD changers.
Tower.
Yeah.
Stack the tower with OCD.
I just opened up my eyes,
just opened up my cabinet with all my
dvds and like all that shit,
which I haven't looked at and I haven't
looked at it and like five,
six years I still have a stack of them.
Vhs tapes that I won't throw A.
Yeah,
there's some of them that I dislike.
I don't think I can get this anywhere.
Do you still have a vhs player?
Yes.
Really?
Yeah.
Whoa.
I haven't even touched it.
I'm curious.
Five years.
I haven't even touched it.
Have you gone back and did you have your
camera?
I just went back and digitize a bunch of
like stuff that I shot on like a,
you know,
my little dv
stuff.
You know what?
I haven't done that and I don't even
know Gunna.
I just feel like,
like let it all go,
let it go.
I feel that way with your inclined to do
that today because everything is.
Everyone's taking photos of everything
and video of everything and I just feel
I don't have time to look at them like
if I went and looked into my iphone from
like seven,
eight years ago,
just started going through all the
pictures of the only thing I keep his
photos of my kids keep those.
I keep photos of your kids to.
Thank you.
That's very kind of you.
I'll go to you if I need backup.
Yeah,
you got it.
Other than that,
that's it.
Yeah.
Just like,
what am I going to do?
Well,
it's like we're,
I feel like we're in A.
I feel like I have a gold fish brain.
Like I feel like I just like swim and
five minutes later it's gone.
You know what I mean?
And I feel like I am constantly in that
space and I feel like we record all this
shit and then we don't really look back.
Maybe some people look back,
but I'm the same way.
I think we're inundated.
We're over
run by information.
I don't think our brains are even
remotely capable of processing the
amount of raw data that comes to you and
have you checked your google news feed,
then you check your twitter feed and
then people send me things in email and
I check those out.
I don't,
I don't have,
I don't have the time or the storage.
It's just,
it goes in and it goes out.
I have.
Well I have,
I just was like,
I use the Google App on my phone to like
search it.
Yeah,
me too.
And I'll go on there,
but now Google's got like stories they,
it thinks I'm going to be interested in
and then I'll be like,
oh fuck,
I guess I gotta look up whatever's going
on.
And then like 30 minutes later I'm like,
why did I go to Google?
What was,
what was I going in there for?
That's my toilet time.
Yes.
I'm taking a dump.
Open that APP up and next thing you
know,
my legs are numb.
Totally.
You're like limping out of the bathroom
with a weird red emperor in impressions
on like right above your knee.
And it doesn't make any sense.
It's like I didn't get anything out of
that thing.
I feel like if you have discipline,
if you could avoid that,
the good stories will come to you.
The ones that you need to hear about,
like,
dude,
if you fucking heard about what happened
to him,
like,
okay,
then you hear it.
Yes it is.
Or because I also,
there was a period of time where I was
like,
not reading the news.
I was parsing,
I was piecing together the news based
off of people's twitter jokes,
you know what I mean?
Where I was like,
okay,
I'm going to put the math together.
I think like,
you know,
I think there's been a hurricane
somewhere.
Um,
but I feel like my downtime,
my pro,
I'm,
I think I'm scared of having actual
downtime because when I have actual
downtime I spent so much time in some of
my phone that.
And that stresses me out.
So like if I'm working,
I don't have time to be looking at my
phone and then I'm like,
just work,
you know what I mean?
But it's,
I'm scared of like downtime.
Yeah.
Downtime,
fallen time,
they are very bad for you.
It's just not healthy.
It's not normal,
it's not a normal interaction.
And if you're like looking at shit that
you're freaking out about that as I was
freaking out today about um,
the,
what's going on in Portland,
there's all these antifa riots that are
happening and they're blocking traffic
and people are trying to drive to their
job and the Antifa people are telling
them go right,
we're closed the street off and they got
like masks on Shit.
And the Portland mayor apparently not
doing anything about it.
And their stress smash some banging on
some dude's car because you refused to
fucking go,
right?
You wanted to go straight through the
street.
Like they were literally directing
traffic and there's all these videos of
where people are freaking out because
Portland is just,
it's a great city.
So fun.
So overly progressive that you have this
section of super far left.
Maniacs that are,
that have gathered and I've found a
cause and now they're,
they've decided that they're going to.
And these are white people screaming
out,
fuck white people.
The whole thing is so crazy.
It's like totally misguided.
I just want to eat delicious food in
Portland.
I just want to eat a place to eat like
fresh food.
It's a good place for comedy too.
It is fun.
It's a great comedy town there.
So yeah,
so the best.
It's just,
you know,
when you get a town of millions of
people,
you're going to have a fucking few
thousand assholes.
There's just no way around that.
Yeah,
everywhere I've gone that I find that
the Pacific northwest is interesting.
Just like I found the homeless vibes in
Portland,
Seattle and San Francisco.
It's intense right now.
You know,
seattle or rather San Francisco has a
new APP that you can locate human shit
on to alert the health department.
It's like a crap.
I love it.
Only in San Francisco there's like,
it's a startup.
We have a giant problem over there.
Dude.
It's intense,
man.
It's intense.
They got too liberal.
They let two.
They were just too open minded with the
homeless folks.
Fuck.
These people are just shitting openly
shitting in the gutter.
Look at that.
Here's the poop.
Oh,
I liked that.
The coloring.
I wonder when they discovered,
they're like,
we can do varying levels of what is that
area that seems to be covered.
Is it like that downtown
embarcadero or like right off the
mission and shit.
Fuck,
look how much shit there is.
That's the area that is crazy.
Like on all those corners as human shit.
Oh man,
that is correct.
And that's not an exaggeration.
I was there.
My friend Jake put it up on his
instagram,
a guy with his pants down just spraying
shit out of his ass into the street.
He was standing on the sidewalk after
this treat.
Just spraying dude.
I mean I do that but that's like I go
but I do it for art.
It's art,
it's my art,
you know what I mean?
And it's for leisure kind to do
something to take public.
Have you ever had a public shooting?
I'm not on purpose.
Yeah,
I shit my pants a couple of times
public,
but I mean I kept it in like inside my
clothes.
I Shit my pants.
I was thinking about,
I was coming in here being like,
to have any,
like I'm like,
I don't do mma,
everything.
I was like,
well,
what did I ever do?
Credit.
I was like,
oh,
right.
I did karate until I was seven and I did
it and I like,
I remember being,
I was in a class with a bunch of,
um,
cops in my town.
They had like a self defense class and I
was friends with like a cop and so he
said,
come take the karate class.
Like,
sure,
we'd go in and take it.
And it was,
and I'm wearing the,
like the gooey and it's fucking,
you know,
I was sick so I just kept nodding it,
you know what I mean?
You're just like,
oh,
I'm fucking on.
And I kept nodding it and then I go to
class and I'd like I'd eaten fettuccine
Alfredo.
I was fucking sitting there and I'm
taking the class,
doing my little kicks and then I'm like,
I got to go to the bathroom and I get to
the bathroom and I can't untie the too
many fucking nuts.
And I just,
I'm six.
I just fucking spray diarrhea down my
down,
my geeky and then like go back to class.
Like all these cops are like dirty
little fuck.
And I was like,
I think that's the last time I took
karate.
That was the end of my mixed martial
arts career.
Yeah,
that can be a problem.
Have you ever fought so hard that you
like lose like mayor?
Does that happen?
Like with Michelle?
Yeah,
like marathon.
I've done that inside the octagon for
sure.
Yeah.
There's actually a new rule in some
athletic commissions.
They stop a fight just for hygiene
concerns.
Someone shits themselves.
Sure.
But it's happened many times.
Yeah,
because you think if you've got an open
wound and you got shit,
there's some real issues.
There's some real duty duty issues
there.
Real problem and there was,
there was that marathon runner who lost
her.
Like that's happened a bunch of times.
Apparently marathon runners shit
themselves all the time.
Just keep running.
I see I'm not that.
Are you that way?
Isn't it like you'll push your leg?
I'm like,
I would never push myself to that point
where I'm like,
yeah,
I'll push myself to the phone.
Really depends on what it meant to me
and I mean if I,
if I had some deep emotional reason to
finish this marathon.
Yeah.
Like my dad died or you know what I
mean?
That
Burton are run marathons,
right?
I don't think he's ever run a marathon.
His Dad did.
His Dad ran a marathon.
His Dad is a holocaust survivor in his
eighties and he ran a six hour marathon
and the.
We were telling Bert,
there's no fucking way you got to beat
or his dad or his dad said,
it's 80.
Bert,
you're a fat.
Fuck.
Did he beat him by like a half hour?
Burt did it in like five hours on birth
or his dad was like seventies,
eighties running a marathon,
ladies.
Yeah,
man,
he's 82.
You can survive the Holocaust man.
What's a fucking marathon?
You know what I mean?
Well,
he was also in the Israeli army.
He's an old dude.
Well,
yeah,
and,
but you look at our,
you're like,
I could see.
It's like there's that.
There's that version of Jus like that
skinny Jew that can run a marathon,
like I buy that.
Yeah,
I could see that.
Well,
when we started doing this fitness thing
already had,
you know,
we have the sober October thing and then
there's this fitness challenge attached
to it and our.
He literally hadn't worked out at all
in,
I think he said 10 years.
I think 10 years ago he was taking
Jujitsu with me.
That's the last time he did any exercise
at all.
How did he,
how is he doing?
He's doing great.
He's in second place right now.
He's right behind me.
It is a game of genetics on some level.
It's just a game of will.
Yeah.
Because this thing,
this thing that we're using,
all it does is measure your heart rate,
so if you're just willing to keep your
heart rate elevated and push yourself,
it just depends on.
Yeah.
Like what is your level of competition?
And you're like that you want to
fucking.
Yeah.
And what is your.
How strong is your will?
That's really what it is.
Is there anything to it?
If it's like if you have an exercise in
10 years and you all of a sudden start
to exercise,
your heart rate goes up naturally
because it's like,
what the fuck's going on?
We're trying to think that maybe he's so
fucking out of shape that he's just like
walking and his heart rate's been,
but I don't think so.
But see this thing is very flawed.
This fucking this thing that we have
because it gives you the same amount of
points for 80 percent of your heart rate
as it does for 90.
So the first day I was like,
I'm gonna burry these motherfuckers and
I pegged my heart rate at 90 for like 35
minutes.
I was like,
I'm just going to leave them in the dust
like they can't keep up.
And then I found out that all you have
to just keep it at 80,
which was like 143 beats per minute,
which is easy.
You walk and talk,
you'll get the 43 if you.
If you're on an elliptical machine,
you could have a full on conversation.
No problem at 143 beats,
right?
So it's flawed.
It's flawed because the end,
there's that difference between 80 and
90 percent where you're like,
you're getting that extra burden.
It's the matter of the sheer time you
put in.
That's,
that's what's separating everybody in
this little challenge at Ari.
We'll put in two and a half hours,
like he will watch a movie and just keep
his heart rate pegged at 100 4,346
beats a minute for two and a half hours.
He wants to fucking beat.
You guys just wants a win and he wants
and he's been talking mad shit about it.
I was,
I was.
At first I was like,
you know what the context is so fucking.
There's no real.
Like,
like there's nothing we haven't
established.
What happens to the loser,
you know,
we haven't established what the winner
gets other than a belt.
We have a belt,
her belt,
like a wwe bill getting one made.
That's so funny,
but it's just,
it doesn't,
that's all just wanting to beat your
friends.
Yes.
But,
and for awhile I was like,
fuck,
I'm just going to do my normal workout
and if they beat me they beat me.
And then I thought about,
I was like,
I can't let that happen.
So I started ramping it up.
I decided over the last couple of days
that it took three days off too because
I had to go to vegas and I had to work
and then I decided,
uh,
yesterday I'm going to fuck these guys
up.
So yesterday and today I've been hitting
it hard.
I did three and a half hours today.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Do you feel good?
Great.
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
yeah.
And physically do you feel different?
Yeah.
Do you do or do not feel different?
Like,
uh,
being completely sober?
Um,
well I'm definitely high as fuck from
all this running.
Yeah.
There's no doubt about that.
That's real.
Like runner's high is legit.
Like if you run for two hours and then a
rock falls in your car from the sky.
But I guess I lost my car.
So silly.
It's a.
and I get the same way from Yoga.
Yes.
Silly.
There's a silliness to you.
Yeah.
I don't.
I hate running so much.
I fucking hate it.
I'd rather go like,
uh,
I started playing soccer again.
Soccer's great.
Yeah.
Which serious?
Aerobics workout.
That's intense.
Like I finished that.
My problem is I turned bright red as
soon as I do anything with any.
And I'm like the color,
like a deep maroon.
And I'm like,
but it's great,
but I need,
I need a game attached to it.
I can't just run.
That's why Jujitsu is so good for me.
That's what I love about you.
Just so you're doing something,
you're trying to,
you know,
you're doing a martial art and it's
exhausting and you get a great workout
in while you're having fun.
Beating the shit out of somebody.
Choking people.
Yeah.
Never mind.
I'm like,
I'll go play soccer and then slightly
injured myself.
Now I'm like,
as I'm getting older,
it's like every time I do it,
I do something.
Fuck up my body.
He definitely can do that.
You know,
we have here.
That's amazing.
We have this htc vive.
It's a virtual reality headset and
there's a boxing game.
Put this headset on and you're standing,
you see boxing gloves in front of you
and there's a dude in front of you,
right?
It looks really good.
Throw punches,
and you get that aerobic workout without
pounding her fucking and he hits you.
You see sparks.
Really.
Boom.
Lucky hit you.
Yeah.
You don't feel anything,
but it makes you nervous.
Like,
damn,
he got me.
Yeah,
like I've done rounds where you,
you've,
you fight these people and you get
exhausted.
Boxing seems to be crazy.
Aerobic workout.
It's great.
Yeah.
It's getting hit in the head thing.
It's fucking terrible for you though.
It's so bad for you.
Yeah,
man,
I can't.
I've never been.
I've been so averse to that shit.
I was talking to Louis about that
because he was boxing for a while and he
was like,
I love sparring.
You're sparring.
He goes,
yeah.
I go,
how often do you sparring?
And he's like,
you sparring quite a bit.
I could do.
I go,
I know you're having a good time,
but you have to understand like there
there's real consequences to this.
You're getting in car accidents
constantly.
You're getting hit.
You're getting hit in the head like that
counts and you're doing it when you're
48 years old like this and you're fat
like so you're not moving a lot and
don't got great headbutts and like your,
your muscles aren't there to like take
whatever that there's real consequences
to getting here.
How often do you do that?
I don't do that at all.
You'll never get hit in the head.
No,
I don't do it at all.
no.
I stopped doing it a long time ago.
It's,
I hit the bag.
I'll hit pads and I would spar with
someone who I know well where I won't
hit them and they won't touch each
other.
It'd be like,
what about you?
Yeah.
What about all these different?
Because it's just choking on bars and
stuff like that.
There's no like there's no hitting each
other.
Know that hitting in the head is fun.
It's fun.
It's fun to hit people.
It's fun to not get hit.
It feels good to take a shot and give
one back,
but the consequences are real and I see
too much of it.
I see.
I see this slow degrading of your
cognitive ability.
I've seen it in too many people.
What do you think?
What do you think anything's going to
happen with football like you think it's
are they going to like.
I think people are going to wise up and
I.
I think fighting is way better for you
than football and I think fighting is
terrible for you.
I think football is the worst because
they're running at each other full clip
and slamming into each other all day.
It's like driving off a cliff constantly
over and over and over again.
Fucking nuts.
We have a friend and they have a kid
who's in high school who has severe
depression from getting football.
He's all fucked up from football and
they can't believe that it happened so
fast.
I would go.
How long has he been playing?
Playing for a couple years.
He's been getting smashed in the head
for years because it's just like you and
you watch like a football practice.
Those students are just like listening
and less and less,
and now I think they're finally
realizing,
but like when we were growing up,
all my buddies played football.
Like every drill was like,
stand in a circle and let's have these
dudes fucking run into each other.
Speed over and over.
Finding out.
Now they're getting hit in the body is
as bad as getting hit in the head.
Really?
Yeah.
Because when you get slammed in the
body,
your head snaps back and your brain goes
whoosh,
whoosh.
Inside your skull.
And it,
you think that concussions only come
from getting a head injury.
It's not the case.
They're finding the people get
concussions from getting hit in the
body.
So this is pure ignorance in boxing or
whatever.
When a guy gets knocked out,
he's getting,
that's a concussion,
right?
Oh yeah.
Most of the time,
right?
Yeah.
And so those guys are just getting.
They're getting concussions all the
time.
Yeah.
And they get concussions even when they
win sometimes.
Like,
um,
there's a guy named Joe Valtellina who's
been on the show before.
He's a world championship kickboxer.
He had to retire after he won
the title.
He won the fight and then afterwards his
head injury was so severe he couldn't
look at the light from a charger,
from a phone,
you know,
like a phone charger.
He had to be in total darkness for
months at a time or for weeks at a time
rather.
And what saved him was actually CBD oil.
Really?
Yeah.
Cbd Oil is pretty good at reducing
inflammation.
It's pretty radical and its effect and
that that brought it all down for them.
I haven't.
I haven't tried cbd oil very much.
Yeah,
it's really good for pain and stuff like
that.
It's great
pain.
It's great for anxiety and one of the
more important things.
It doesn't fuck with you.
Like cognitively.
Yeah.
It doesn't make you high.
It's not right.
So you can do it and just go do stuff,
but it alleviates anxiety.
Calms you down.
Where do they think that maybe some
anxiety may coincide with inflammation?
Oh,
that makes sense.
Like physical inflammation,
that it.
It makes sense.
Oil,
you know,
drops,
oil drops.
It's also good for just your,
just your overall,
your whole system,
your gut biome.
It's good for everything.
Yeah.
I've just been smoking weed forever.
That's good too.
That helps.
I went to a,
I went to burning man this year and uh,
did,
had just a fucking wild time of,
because I know you've talked about it.
I'd never done acid before.
I did ask him for the first time.
How was it?
It was fascinating.
I've done,
I've done mushrooms like somewhat
regularly for most of my adult life,
like not,
not crazy amounts but like,
you know,
once a year depending on,
um,
and always loved it.
I'm like,
I was like,
if I were left with one thing might be
that one because I liked the warmth,
like the organic,
the giggles,
the warmth and like everything love
everybody.
I love everybody and it is what I,
you know,
when people used to talk about like what
ecstasy was,
I was like,
oh,
that's mushrooms.
Like you just feel giggly and warm and
connected.
Um,
but I was like,
you know what we're going to have.
I'm going to burning man.
Couple buddies were like,
I've,
I've done this acid before and I haven't
read the Michael Pollan book,
but I was like,
enough,
there's enough gut to know you've been
talking about it.
There's enough around there that I'm
like,
I'm ready.
Like,
because I remember in my late twenties
someone being like trying to buy
mushrooms in there.
Like I got asked and I was like,
I'm not going to do it.
Like I had,
you know,
at least when we were kids,
there was that fear that like you do
acid,
you could fry your brain forever and you
never come back.
Right.
And I don't know if that was the kind of
asset people were doing or if it just.
People were doing a ton of it.
They,
they think now that what that is,
it's,
it's people that are schizophrenic,
right.
And there's a certain percentage of the
population,
like they were trying to make a
correlation between marijuana use in
schizophrenia that it causes
schizophrenia,
but they found out that the numbers are
the same as the general population.
The numbers of people who use marijuana
becomes schizophrenia because the same
numbers is just you take 100 people,
there's going to be one of them is going
to be schizophrenic or whatever the
number is,
whether it's one percent or higher and
they,
there's,
they think though that it can exacerbate
the situation and it can actually bring
it on.
Like say maybe if someone has maybe sort
of a manageable cause.
Schizophrenia exists like many diseases
do on a spectrum.
Sure.
You know,
this is really bad.
Cancer and his people have a mild
cancer.
They get over well with schizophrenia if
they do acid or if they do,
I'm even edible.
Marijuana apparently can bring it
shit,
man.
I don't think I'm frantic,
but anytime I feel like I am,
I can't eat it.
I can't.
I'm just like,
immediately
the thing is a little.
You got to do baby doses.
That's the king.
The key with edible marijuana is great
at about 10 to 20 milligrams.
Then you get to that Joey Diaz level
where he's doing 500,000
big boy.
He's,
he's,
he's not,
but even he quit.
He quit edibles.
Really?
Yeah,
he quit.
I can't,
I just like early on I was like,
I tried edibles and I just remember,
I remember,
I remember being in Austin,
I don't know if it was south by or
whatever,
and I had like a cookie,
like a little bit of a,
it was earlier,
much earlier than now,
how regulated things are and I ate a
little bit and like went back to my
hotel room and I was like,
I can't even look.
I was like,
I can't look at the screen.
And I just walked the streets,
went to the city,
the capital of the state capital and
just looked at the pit,
like portraits of the former governors
of Texas and then was like,
got like sober ish.
And then my buddies were like,
we're going to a gun range.
And I was like,
I went to a gun range and it was like,
I was like,
I'm not firing a gun,
but I'll just like.
And I was like,
Ooh,
it was like eight hours later and I'm
still like a mess.
But,
uh,
but,
but I was like,
you know what,
I'm going to burning man.
I'm going to try acid,
I want with my buddy was my college
roommate.
Neither of us had done it before a guide
given it to us who I was like,
I've done this asset.
I know how to do it.
He's like,
I recommend taking the assassin and
listening to classical music and eating
fruit.
That was his.
And I was like,
all right.
I was like,
I like listening to classical music and
eat fruit.
And I was like,
I like classical music and I like fruit.
So I was looking.
I was like,
this sounds great.
so we're out in the fucking desert and
we eat it on our last day.
And have you been to burning man?
No,
I,
I thought it was,
I was kind of blown away.
I've found it.
I've enjoyed it very,
very much fucking weird.
I mean,
sure,
but it's,
I dunno,
it was like people executing whatever
they're doing incredibly well and
there's a lot of different versions of
it and stuff,
but it's kind of,
um,
there's a lot of pranksters.
They're like,
there's,
it's actually not.
It's like there's a hippy dippy quality
to it,
but then there's some real people kind
of fucking with people in a fun way that
I got a kick out of,
but we took the,
took acid and like,
I don't know,
four and we start,
we're driving around the desert.
You know,
you're,
everyone's on bikes.
You're just on a bike driving around.
Did you have to wear a mask?
No,
the dust was fine.
It was cool and like we start kind of
feeling it and I have had visuals on
mushrooms before,
but this,
all of a sudden like the meltedness of
everything started to set in and the.
Have you done acid in the desert before?
No,
never in the desert.
It's a,
it's a good,
good place.
A good place for it.
Just because like,
visually what's happening is like,
um,
is pretty interesting.
Like we went,
we were driving around on bikes and we
see these immediately.
Then like some couples,
like can you take a picture of us as we,
um,
like try to do a duo yoga pose with the
sunset.
I'm like,
okay,
I'm trying to deal with my camera.
You know what I mean?
And you're like,
okay,
I think I think this is what you want,
you know,
and then we drive away from there and
there are these like porn stars who
wanted pictures of the are taking
pictures of themselves and I was like,
we're like,
you know,
we're in the burning man spirit of like
we'll give him the gift of our music and
like they don't want,
they don't want.
I'm not even hitting nothing.
I'm just like literally like driving
around.
We've got our little like,
you know,
our little bluetooth speaker playing
classical music and they aren't,
they don't give a fuck.
They don't want any of it.
And then we go and sit and,
and we're just now starting to peak
right at sunset in the desert.
And it's like,
it was,
it was like,
oh,
this feels like a,
some version of what heaven feels like,
you know,
like where the sky,
the colors in the sky are unbelievable.
And all of a sudden all the desert,
all the sand,
you know this,
it's like this real fine alkaline dust.
And it's like,
you feel like you're seeing some real
like grid work,
you know,
I don't know if you have that feeling
where you're like,
oh,
I can feel like I'm seeing some
underlying dynamics of the structural
stuff.
I've seen that on mushrooms.
He,
yeah.
It feels like you're witness to the
pattern of things.
Like there's some sort of.
Yeah,
the structure of things.
Yeah.
And that's what it felt like.
You were like,
you're looking at this like this crazy,
you know,
and you've got.
Yeah.
So you're,
you're seeing the sand,
this very fine light sand with the
really red mountains.
And then the blue really crisp blue sky
with,
with uh,
the white clouds.
And it felt like you were like,
oh,
I'm seeing some structural shit that's
going on.
It's,
it was quite.
And we're listening to this Guy Eric
said,
steve's like a classical musician and
eating cherries and this is pretty
fucking sweet.
And I was like,
it's cool that you followed it to a t.
You went with the fruit and know why
not?
Let's just have it,
you know,
why not.
And I think classical music is,
but it was interesting because I,
I didn't.
So then,
so then the sun sets and it's like,
even at the height of it,
it didn't feel warm like mushrooms have
felt.
It felt like co clinical.
Clinical.
Exactly.
That's exactly the worry about that.
Uh,
it's very interesting that you said he
took it riding bikes too,
because that's in a lot of ways in Omaj
to Albert Hoffman.
That's how he found out about it.
You know,
he synthesize lsd and you know,
got it in his skin when he was working
with it and then rode his bike home and
on the bike ride home realized,
oh my God,
whoa.
Fucking tripping balls here without even
knowing what tripping.
I mean he,
he knew something was going on and eat
it.
I mean,
he may,
I believe,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but I believe the initial reason for
creating Lsd,
I think they were,
they were trying to come up with a drug
to induce labor.
I'm pretty sure that was the original.
I think that's what they were working
on.
And in the process synthesized LSD and
Lsd as a compound and it's one of those
unbelievably potent compounds where
someone,
I think it was terrence,
we kind of described it as the power to
weight ratio is so huge that it's like
if you had one aunt that dismantled the
statue of Liberty in 30 minutes,
like that's how,
that's how potent LSD is.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean I took,
it actually said the empire state
building.
She's,
I mean I took,
I took a,
a responsible amount.
Like I was like,
I don't need to like
losing my mind here.
I've only microdosed at ovenly.
Well one,
one time I doubled the mic,
but still it was a small dose.
If it was enough to just like I had
planned the synthesis of the compound
with the intention of obtaining a
circulatory and respiratory stimulant.
Hoffman wrote the new substance,
however arose no special interests in
our pharmacologics pharmacologists and
physicians.
Testing was therefore discontinued.
Huh?
Why did I think I said 25th attempt
aptly named Lsd?
Twenty five.
Not knowing he was not after like a
psychedelic drug.
No,
I don't believe so.
Dose to four,
20:00
PM.
Y'All look at it and go down and look at
that.
Go Down Clarius.
Yeah.
He dosed himself for 20 most intense
from six to 8:00
PM during that time he rode home on his
bicycle.
It's the best.
It feels great.
So the,
so we,
we,
we sort of are peeking around sunset and
it's like,
it feels like I'm with my buddy of 20
years I've known him since college.
We've gone through our lives together
and there's a thing when you eat,
when you trip,
where you're like that space time
continuum thing.
There's like,
it feels less linear time where you're
like I'm having thoughts that I had 20
years ago and I'm having them today and
I'm going to have them in 20 years in
like where this,
the nature of all of this feels a little
less,
you know?
And I'm with my buddies had been a
witness to my life,
you know?
So we're having this great large
conversation about our lives and all
that shit and the sun setting.
It's beautiful.
And then it gets dark and it's like,
all right,
let's go watch the man burn now.
Like you know that at burning man,
everybody gathers 70,000
people gather.
You go to this big central area where
the man who has been sitting there for
seven days is then there's like a crazy
fire starter show,
fireworks go off and then you burn this
30 foot man and it's dark and it's
night.
And,
and it's like it was the other side.
It felt like heaven and hell,
you know,
where you're all of a sudden.
And that's where I felt like it was
weird because like that's where I felt
the clinical thing where I'm like,
I feel sort of high,
but I now feel actually quite in a weird
way quite sober.
And I'm,
I felt like I'm witnessing these things
and I feel removed from them in a way
that when you're.
I feel like when you're on mushrooms in
some way you're like,
you feel kind of inside of the,
the flow of,
of,
of nature.
And.
But I was also like,
it's the end by the time of the end of
burning man,
like there are people there all week and
building it and putting all this stuff
together and artists.
It's interesting.
And then like there is definitely have a
section of burning man which is just
like super wealthy people showing up for
like debauchery and,
and like to be around models who were
nearly naked and it's like.
And that's when you look around and,
and,
and the aesthetic of burning man is like
somewhere between like I'm Mad Max,
game of thrones and Tron.
It's somewhere in that space which is
fucking Rad.
But then when you were kind of on acid
and you're kind of looking around and I
had this feeling of like the rich are
here to collect their spoils.
You know what I mean?
Like these.
Do you think that having the great
experience of seeing the sky in the
desert and all the beauty and when
you're like wow this is amazing.
And then when you have something like a
fire and then on top of that you have a
giant group of people.
It seemed and then you realize there's
not really a lot of law enforcement here
and like just seems like it could be
completely chaotic.
Yeah,
it's.
And it is like the fire itself is
protected because I think someone ran
into the fire last year.
Died,
right?
Yeah.
Fucking killed himself.
Joe Ran right into that fire this year
was like,
this year was pretty well regulated like
because we had seen a couple nights
before at sunrise there was like,
you know,
they have all this.
It's what I found too,
it was like the kind of the duality of
adult,
like burning man feels very much like
there's this like sacred and profane
shit all happening together and it's
oftentimes pretty cool.
And like sunrise a couple mornings
earlier,
there's this like 20 foot wooden dragon
statue that someone had built and they
are,
they light it on fire,
you know,
they're just like,
now we're going to burn it.
Like some dude had spent a year making
this statue is like now we're going to
fucking burn it.
And so there,
there were park rangers all around it
and so there's no getting inside.
They light it on fire and then the sun
rises over to the left and then you
looked at.
I looked up and there were like 30
people parachuting out of the sky at
sunrise and you're just like,
what the fuck is going on?
But it was,
it was really cool.
I really,
I enjoyed that.
But by the time Saturday rolled around,
you know,
there is something about fire that's
very primal and you can feel like
there's like there's some pagan quality
to it all and it's cool,
but it's like you could feel like
everybody's like energy kind of getting
a little darker and more primal and,
and I hit a point where I was like,
all right guys,
I gotta I gotta get out of this like 75.
And I also had a fear of like,
I wasn't scared of the fire.
I was scared of like I was seated
watching and I was like,
I'm scared of a trampling.
Yeah,
that's what I mean by like the giant
group of people.
And then also with a fire and then a
gathering when,
when you're dealing with a big
gathering,
there's always the potential for someone
acting out whether they just need a lot
of attention or they go crazy or mean.
Think about adverse reactions to
psychedelics.
Yes.
And 70,000
people,
the potential for something going
haywire is pretty high.
Yeah.
Well,
what I found interesting over the whole
week was because I was pretty skeptical.
I didn't go in.
I went in being like,
I want to experience this thing that a
lot of people have experienced.
I just want to know what that experience
is.
Um,
but what I've found fascinating is
there's,
there's some law enforcement around,
there's some ranges around,
but there's really no,
it's pretty anarchical,
like there's really very little but in
is in so much.
There's actually like some unspoken
rules that basically everybody's Kinda
following,
which I found kind of fascinating where
you're like,
there's no.
Everybody's on bikes.
They're crazy art cars running around
with like fucking shooting fire into the
air.
But there's no,
there seems to be no like regulatory
board being like,
let me make sure that the,
you're crazy 30 foot three tiered iron
car is up to standard.
There seems to be very little of that.
And yet it all seems to function pretty
smoothly.
Like there's some unspoken acceptance of
certain rules.
I'm sure there are people freaking out.
I know there are people like it,
but it's mostly people like being like I
took too much drugs and I didn't hydrate
and like they go to the medic and there.
But like weirdly I've found it all
operating pretty smoothly.
Uh,
but that's when the,
the,
uh,
the acid then sort of turned a bit where
I was,
there's some darkness here that I want
to get away from.
It seems like whenever you have a
situation where you've got a bunch of
people that want to do something outside
the norm,
they want to get together and they want
to experience something that's just
their board society.
And this is their big break.
And it seems like there's,
there's so much expectations and there's
kind of a code that these people want to
follow and that code is that,
you know,
it's almost like a utopian vision of a
better society,
even if it's for only a week or so.
Yeah.
And I think it works for a week.
Like,
I don't know if society.
I don't know how a society would
function and like largely lawless.
I mean the biggest rules are like don't
put your trash anywhere.
Like there's no garbage cans anywhere.
Don't pee outside like p and a Porta
Potty,
pee in a jug ticket back,
dump it out because there's no mark,
no leave,
no,
no mark.
And it works.
But I guess it works for a week where
you're like,
everybody's agreed for that week and
then you go back to your life.
But like,
I dunno,
it was,
I got a fucking kick out of it.
Like there's.
And there's,
you know,
there's like we,
there's one night,
you know,
there are all these crazy light shows at
night.
It,
it becomes like this crazy tron,
like light show everywhere you look,
you see the horizon for as far as you
can see is just like people on bikes
that are all lit up,
crazy art cars,
crazy pieces of art that are lit up.
Um,
and it's really wild.
But like you go,
you know,
you ride around bikes and there were all
of a sudden we roll up to this area
where there's a,
like a mechanical arm holding these
lights that are,
um,
led lights that are in this,
you know,
in a circle and you lie below it and
it's like a light show,
you know,
it's this like vortex light show.
So everybody's kind of looking up at it
and it's really trippy and fun.
And impairment was like,
Whoa,
that's a trippy.
And I laid down and I was like,
this is red.
And then this dude rolls up.
My friend sees us,
uh,
you know,
those costumes of like,
um,
uh,
those like tyrannosaurus rex like that
they're inflated and the kind of or
like,
you know,
you see like dude's like one individual
sides things,
but they're like,
it's super weird.
So I look at this guy and I start
cracking up and my buddy just took that
turn a source rex and walked him through
the middle of everybody having their
quiet trippy moment,
you know,
so like this just kind of rolls through
it and he's just like,
hey,
you know,
and he's just like,
he was here before you,
you know,
and it's like,
so it's kind of fun.
It's just like everybody's like having
their trippy moment and then it gets
fucked up and then a minute later
they're back to the trippy moment.
You know,
I,
I got a real,
I got to fucking kick out of.
It was weird.
I don't know if that would work longterm
either because you'd have to have
resources,
right?
You have to have food and water and
land.
And then who controls the food?
Water and land.
I think one of the things,
the reason why it works so well is
because it's
outside of culture,
like south side of civilization.
You go to a place and everybody meets
their.
Yes,
yes.
Nobody has an established like dominance
or domain over it at all.
You just are entering on the same page
and talking about this a lot lately.
Like cults never work like there's not a
single,
like one of these wild wild country
things or you know,
a waco or the guys in the.
What was the one in San Diego?
They cut their balls out of.
Yeah.
Gave.
They never work.
No one has nailed it.
Like how come no one can,
but burning man's kind of nailed it.
They've been.
The way they nailed it is they just do
it for a little bit and then they go
back to life and it's,
I guess the guy who founded it or is one
of them passed away this past year,
so they think he was in the middle of
the burn this year and.
But even he is.
It's not a cult of personality.
Like I think that's the thing,
you know,
if you decentralize that and at the
center of it is like,
is this fucking man burning?
Is like,
I think if you take that element away,
I think the problem with culture is
they're all there.
I mean,
is there any code that isn't like driven
by one central force?
It's always a person.
It's always a person that always gets
fucked up because that person uses it or
an and it's all run through them and
then if he or she goes away,
then it's the next round of that person.
They're always,
it's always playing off of this weird
Alpha chimpanzee instinct that we have
to have like a big daddy,
the daddy that has all the messages and
is in touch with God or the Ufo behind
the asteroid or whatever the fuck it is.
There's always this one person,
whether it's Jim Jones or you know,
fill in the blank.
There's someone who has all the answers
and there's a weird desire that people
have to,
to look to this one person that has all
the answers.
Yes.
It's very,
it's.
Well,
it's a tribal thing.
It's traveling and it's specifically if
you're someone who gets into a cult,
you are searching for something,
you're searching for some solidity or or
something and and if you've got that
person at the middle is like,
I got you,
don't worry,
I'll give you.
I'll give you the way it often works.
People are like,
oh thank God.
Yeah,
you know,
but I was thinking I was thinking about
like scientology and being like,
well shit man.
Tom Cruise,
like if you can learn to fly a
helicopter in like four months,
like maybe it's not so bad.
Bill Bergen,
fly helicopter.
No he doesn't.
He didn't use scientology,
the helicopter instructor,
but it took them probably a couple of
years.
I don't think it took them that long,
but Gilbert did fucking billboard is a
dude who likes to like figure stuff out.
Yeah.
He's a really good drummer.
Seen him drum.
I mean I know.
I mean I think I've seen like a youtube
of it,
but I'm like he could be in a band.
Yeah.
But in his cars like he is,
he is building that truck.
Like he is old,
68,
68 Ford pickup?
I think so,
yeah.
Yeah.
That thing's cool.
That's got,
um,
that's a manual transmission on the
column.
It's one
of those weird old school ones where we
shift the gears like next to the
steering wheel.
That's how they used to do it.
Yeah.
But I think they called it three on the
tree and he fucking loves.
I mean that's a brain that likes that
stuff and likes,
like wants to learn to master flying a
helicopter.
There's a couple,
there's a couple of improvisors I know
too,
like who were like a Thomas middleditch
learn to fly a plane.
My Buddy Neil Casey,
I'm like,
that stuff is a real.
I'm like hobbyists in that way.
My,
I'm just like,
I don't care.
You don't have any hobbies.
I like hiking and I like,
uh,
that's a good exercise.
Yeah.
I,
my brain wants it.
My brain wants that.
And,
and I do yoga now.
Do the hot yoga or regular yoga,
regular yoga to do hot yoga.
Hot Yoga.
Just get that fucking sweat.
Yeah,
it's,
uh,
there's,
there's a study that they just did on it
or they're,
they're in the process of doing it right
now at Harvard where they're trying to
find out whether you can get similar
results to sauna that you get for hot
yoga because they think it's a similar
situation.
The top with what's called sidechains
heat shock proteins.
And what would they showed in these
saunas studies.
Is that 20 minutes a day,
four times a week decreased all cause
mortality by 40 percent.
All cause all cause mortality,
meaning heart attack,
stroke,
cancer from just sweating and sweating
it out.
Yeah.
Well your body reacts to that extreme
heat when it's,
I believe the number.
What did Ron say?
Was it one 80?
I think she said 180 degrees.
One slash 71 80 or something like that.
One seven year one eight.
And you do that for 20 minutes four
times a week and it's,
there's a radical decreasing of your,
just your overall systemic inflammation
because of that.
And that's getting it.
That hot makes you less inflamed because
it's like,
right,
we got it out of our system there.
Well,
your body reacts to it.
Your body reacts to that.
He and it produces these heat shock
proteins and these heat shock proteins
apparently had just fantastic at
decreasing inflammation all throughout
your body.
I gotta figure that out because it's all
based for me.
Is like turning red one here.
Yeah,
fucking love it.
I use it all the time almost every day
and you just sweat it out.
Go in there and crank that bitch up.
And I found that air pods.
You can put air pods and they don't
overheat.
Your phone will overheat.
Yes.
You can't have your phone in there.
It'll shut off.
Yeah.
But you could have your phone outside
the song and have the air pods on and
you can just listen to a podcast or
listen to a book on tape.
What are you listening to?
A visually podcasts?
Yeah.
He lives in New York.
Not,
I listened to mine if it sucked or if
it's something that I need to,
uh,
like Rhonda Patrick,
she's spouting out science and I have to
hear it over and over again to get it
into my stupid brain.
Yeah.
But um,
or if I have liked that podcast sucked
and I need to listen to it to find out
where it went off the rails,
know,
because that's.
Yeah,
that's isn't that the bummer of being a
try to be a good at what you do is being
like paying more attention to the shit
that doesn't work.
I have to like a bad sets,
bad comedy sense.
I always listen to those.
I fucking hate him.
I don't even like listen to the good
ones,
but the bad ones are ruthlessly painful.
Fuck
yes.
And I got to listen to the good ones
because I'm.
Because I'm like,
what did I not like?
W W,
w what was so special about me?
But being like,
oh I improvise this,
this and this.
So that's big too.
But the problem is like part of the joy.
The reason it was fun because it felt
fresh and then you try to recreate it
and it just doesn't have the same
fucking juice.
It's possible to recreate some things.
Yes.
Some things they just.
They were in the moment,
the audience.
This is a thing that the audience knows
to like if you have a.
have you ever seen a guy who's faking
improvising?
It's the saddest thing ever.
When you see someone work the crowd and
then you go,
this guy's brilliant and they see him
the next night he does the same shit and
you go,
oh,
it's a trek.
Yeah,
well you,
you can.
There's a moment that happens when
you're improvising with an audience
where someone says something and you
just have the perfect response out of
nowhere.
They know that you just came up with it
and nowhere and it just works,
but there's also lines that you add to a
bit that just came up out of nowhere and
maybe they just crushed that night,
but they're still viable.
There's something to it you to figure
out how to
create it.
Yes,
but it's that.
It's that feeling also of not wanting to
be a how do you build material onstage,
keep it,
have it feel fresh without feeling like
a fraud.
Like a parliament.
Judicious.
Yeah.
Which I think is,
which is sort of like the tricky,
the tricky thing to do.
You got to be less self aware and you
got to be more involved.
Like for me at least I have to be more
connected to the idea that I'm saying
like I have to recreate my own personal
wonderment that's involved in the idea
because they can smell it if you have
to.
Like you have to really be in the
moment.
Like if you're doing a bit about bottled
water,
you have to be thinking about bottled
water.
Like you have to be like what in the
fuck it and then it has to be real.
It has to be.
But if you're not thinking about it and
you're just saying the words,
they fucking smelly,
smelly animals,
they fucking know it.
Yeah.
Even when they,
even when they're psyched to see you and
they liked you,
it's still there.
Still like a weird thing.
You're not in it.
Yeah,
I can,
but you got to be warm or you back out.
You're,
you're,
I mean I've seen you doing spots.
You're back out building the new.
Yeah,
I'm at like 25,
30 minutes.
Fuck Ish.
Right now I just can't seem to because
it's a grind.
It's a grind man.
And I just like,
I don't know how I'm like,
I do my show.
We do,
you know,
we,
we write big mouth that takes us like
five,
six months to write and voice it.
And then,
and when I'm writing all day,
it's tough to go out new spots at night.
What was it like to break it up to do
your Broadway Gig for awhile?
Yeah,
it was great.
I mean that was the most fun that was
like me and Melanie do.
We did it off Broadway,
uh,
for like 25 days,
something like that.
And then toward it a little bit,
five days in Boston,
five days in DC,
la,
New York,
whatever.
And on New York.
Um,
and then we went back into the Broadway
show.
We did 140 shows like 138 shows every
night,
you know,
five show weekends.
And that was the most fun.
That was the most fun because it's,
you're onstage with your buddy.
Um,
so you got someone even on the nights is
not working,
you know,
when you're doing a show and you're
like,
I know they liked me,
but this is not fun.
They're tired,
whatever.
And you got it right,
but you're up there alone.
All of a sudden you're,
you got someone else up there who you
can make eye contact with me.
Like,
fuck these fucking,
let's fuck them a little bit.
You know what I mean?
Without saying a word we both know we're
like,
let's fuck with them tonight.
Um,
and we,
because we wrote it,
we could improvise,
change whatever we wanted every night.
It was like having a standup set that
you could improvise with your buddy in
character that was,
you knew every beat you had to hit,
but you had a lot of freedom within it.
It was,
it was the most fun.
So it's like stand up but not.
Yeah,
like it was largely we built it to be
presentational so we could talk to the
audience at any point because there's
something about doing like a play or
even when I was early on doing sketch,
it's embarrassing,
you know what I mean?
You're like,
we're going to,
I guess we're going to pretend like
we're in a fucking Chinese restaurant
right now,
but you're in the audience were all in
the same room right now.
It's like,
it sucks to not be able to do a joke and
not have a work and not be able to like
talk to the audience about it or be
angry at the audience directly or
whatever it is.
So we could do that.
So we are presentational like you're
doing standup,
but we've written this play that has
real scenes in it.
And then we built in an interview in the
middle where we would interview
different people like on the,
on the Netflix special,
Steve Martin and uh,
and we also had Michael J.
Fox was on special as well,
but every night it was someone different
and it was anyone from,
you know,
we got letterman to do it,
but we also had like Robin Byrd,
remember Robin Byrd,
she was the channel Jay cable access
porn stripper interview show in New York
and like the eighties and nineties,
there is no reason you would know it
except if like you were 13 and going to
sleep at your friend's house in the city
and jerking off the fucking street
troopers getting interviewed like I was.
I kind of remember the name.
I kind of remember that Google,
Robin Byrd,
you'll see some old.
There she is,
you know,
it was like you could just the quality
of that kind of like cable access,
eighties New York Shit.
Um,
we had her on the show because we felt
like our boys would be interacting with
Robin Byrd,
you know.
Um,
so we'd have her and then we add like,
you know,
crazy.
So every night we got to interview
someone different.
It's like a mini live podcasts in the
middle of the show.
So we just built the most fun show for
us to do every night.
It was great,
it was the most fun.
And then we finished that and then came
back and I did that.
We wrote that,
we did that in between season one and
season two of a big mouth,
uh,
because it takes so long to write it and
the to animate it and all that stuff.
So that was.
So we,
we wrote voice most of big mouth season
two before,
uh,
you know,
last year just takes forever.
So in the time that you did it,
you did,
you do stand up at all while you're
doing or just did it while we were
doing.
Oh,
hello.
There was no standup at all.
We're doing big mouth.
We,
I'd go out and do like a couple spots
here and there,
like exhausting timewise.
Yeah,
it's just like nine hours,
10 hours and you're just pitching jokes
all day long.
And it's like,
you know,
for me I do a bunch of the voices on the
show.
So I'm pitching for myself,
I'm pitching for my,
you know,
all the other characters.
And you're just,
at any given moment,
you're watching,
you're writing,
you're breaking in episode,
you're rewriting another episode,
you're giving notes on a radio play of
an just the audio,
you're giving notes on a the animatic
screening that's coming black,
which is like the black and white kind
of rough draft and you're giving notes
on a color screening that's come back
from Korea from like six months ago.
So you're kind of at any given moment
your rewrite,
especially when you're in the middle of
the season,
you're just,
you're just kind of,
yeah,
you're just given your,
your rewrite.
It's the beauty of animation to that.
You just keep getting fucking,
you know,
figure stuff out when something's not
working or just keep,
you know,
it's the,
it's good for that kind of perfectionist
Polisher of like what you're talking
about,
where you like,
you're like,
what's not working?
You keep getting it figured out what's
not working,
you know,
versus like live action where you're
like,
I hope I got it.
You know,
it's gotta be that's incredibly time
consuming and it must be exhausting.
It,
it Kinda is.
It's at the end of the day,
you're like,
am I going to go ahead and do a spot
now?
Yeah,
I dunno.
I mean I think there's a balance,
right?
Like you can't burn yourself out too
much because then you won't have the
jokes for the next day.
You'll be too fried.
You gotta pace yourself.
I mean everybody works differently.
Our pacing is pretty good that like
you're,
you're.
Yeah.
I mean there are certain times where I'm
like,
Ooh,
I feel cooked,
but it's like anything else where you're
like,
you train your brain in that space where
you're like,
the first two weeks you come home,
your brain is exhausted at the end of
the night and then two weeks in you're
like,
oh,
okay.
I got my endurance back up.
Like I can do that.
I can do that nine hour day.
Did
you.
What did you do to keep your energy
level during the day?
Did you take any nootropics are doing.
It would actually be curious because I
get,
I get hammered at like 2:30
PM.
I want a nap and I can't and I'm,
but I'm like,
I'm not thinking or acting like you are.
So I'm like coffee in the morning and
then um,
you know,
and then I crashed and I eat sugar and
then I thought,
crap.
I'm like,
I don't know what I'm supposed to be.
I'll take any,
any advice you got.
I would say
the sugar part is the biggest thing you
should get rid of.
Yeah.
That's the thing that makes it crashed
the hardest to greet and donuts and
shit.
They taste delicious,
but you,
your body has a really hard time
processing that shit.
And afterwards you just bull.
Like the other day I was in Vegas and
because it was a on a Sunday,
I was like,
ah,
fuck it man.
I'll just have some pancakes or
something like that.
So I had crepes and I had um,
this yogurt with all this.
It was like,
you know,
now like yogurt with fruit in it and
shed and uh,
had a.
oh and I had two cupcakes or to,
to uh,
to donuts because they had homemade
donuts at the hotel.
Like,
all right,
call,
I'll get a couple of days.
I felt like dog shit for the next six
hours.
I was just like,
oh yeah.
I felt like I had been drugged.
Like I was exhausted.
Your body's probably truly not used to
like I've trained my customer to it,
so yeah.
But I think there's a certain amount of
you get accustomed to that terrible
feeling and it's just the normal feeling
you have after you eat.
But even after like even let's say I
have like a Greens and protein lunch,
like where I'm like fuck it,
I'm having a salad with chicken and or
something like that.
Still I just hit that like my body wants
15 minutes to close its eyes at like
2:30
PM.
Whatever is happening on the couch in
your office.
We'll do that.
Yeah.
I need to schedule that.
I need to schedule better into the day.
It'd be like,
Hey guys,
I'm walking away right now because
that's all it needs is like 15 minutes.
But are like,
what?
What is the,
is it just a,
what is it like?
Is it a,
you have different companies that make
them.
What they are is essentially the
building blocks for human
neurotransmitter's.
There's a,
there's a gummies like powder most of
the time.
Either you take them in capsule form or
you,
uh,
you drink it.
Here's a good company that uh,
that makes one called a neuro one.
I really liked that one because it's got
caffeine in it too.
Um,
and then there's another one called true
brain.
That's a good one.
My company makes one called Alpha brain.
That's my favorite one,
not just because it's my company,
but I think we did the best job of
putting ingredients in that work
synergistically.
But I'd take a neuro one a lot.
I liked that one a lot.
How do you,
how do you take it during the ticket?
In a shake.
I just,
I just mix it with water in the morning,
like,
or just whenever you need it.
Whenever I'll take it before a workout.
I'll take it before a podcast.
It'll take.
I take Alpha before every UFC.
Yeah.
What it is is it helps you.
It's been clinically proven through two
double blind placebo controlled studies
at Boston Center from memory that it
increases verbal memory,
like your ability to find the right word
for a sentence,
uh,
increases your reaction time.
Sure.
When you're doing the UFC shit,
you just have to be ready to.
Yeah.
There's just no,
there's no live.
Yeah.
And I'm recounting thousands of fights,
like if you hear me talk and I don't use
notes really.
I mean I have some notes in front of me
that like I'll get a guy's record or
seven and now especially guys that I
haven't seen fight too many times.
There's a few things that I'd like to
just arrest events,
like almost if it's all in the back of
my head.
So I'm recounting a thousand plus.
Do you have,
has your memory always been like that
for fights?
For fights?
Are fights in certain things for
certain,
for certain things,
but like my wife will tell me something
in like an hour later.
I'm like,
what?
You told me that?
And she like,
she's like,
I just fucking told you that.
Well I was.
Yeah,
I was having a conversation with a
friend recently.
It was like,
it was like,
well I remember that your friend is
Brazilian,
but I have no idea where I was in April.
Yeah,
it's like I don't know what that is now.
I don't know if my memory was bad.
Like I also with the show,
luckily my partners are great detail
oriented.
Like I,
I'm like improvising in the room writing
blah blah blah blah.
And I like,
I don't,
I don't want to type anything.
I just want to like belittle a verbal.
It's just all verbal and then I'll like
watch a cut of the show and I'll have
almost no memory of what I've said.
And then I'm like,
oh that was funny.
I'll have no memory of where it came
from,
where it came from,
nothing.
And then I'll watch it and be like,
okay great,
we'll figure it out.
But like it just seems to be the way and
I don't know if that's what I've done to
my brain or that's just the way it is.
I think the funny people,
a lot of times they think and sort of
that abstract way and that usually
doesn't lend itself to the best memory.
It's sort of a wild,
loose,
impulsive,
abstract quality that in my opinion,
the my friends,
the funniest friends that I have sort of
have that thing going on.
We write your job.
Do you write your jokes ahead of time?
Do you need.
I do
now.
I've been doing that over the last maybe
four or five years have changed what I
do,
but I used to do is I would have things
that I wrote down in notebooks and I
would write a little bit on a computer,
but maybe four or five years ago I got
a.
became very diligent with my writing and
so I write out,
I'll write and rewrite and do it all
over again.
Start it from scratch and then go,
yeah,
sorry.
Go ahead.
Know,
and then.
Then I put it into a thing called
scrivener,
scrivener.
You ever use that?
I mean I know it is what I'm using.
I use that so I could switch it to the
lefthand side or it's a.
all the column is all the different
subjects and then I can move them
around.
I can put this one first,
that one second,
and then when I click on each one that
it takes me to all of the shit that I've
written on that particular subject.
I've just found that it makes a big
difference in my.
My output quality material.
Like how much stuff.
That's good.
Taglines.
I never forget the taglines anymore.
[inaudible].
Are you visually seeing when you're
onstage or you're visually seeing the
tagline in your head?
Yeah.
What I do with onstage,
what the thing that I do before I go on
stage,
like that day,
usually within a couple of hours of
performing,
I write things out in a notebook.
If you look at my notebook,
it's like all work.
No play makes jack a dull boy.
Oh work.
I say I write the same thing over and
over again,
like 40 pages because it's just a memory
book.
Yes.
I should call it a memory book rather
than a notebook.
It's very little of it.
Is actual writing.
Most of it is just like,
I just want to make sure that I write
down all the beats to whatever bit.
Yes,
yes.
I,
I've never found an organizational
method that I like and can stick to in
that way.
Like my,
my shit is like,
there's like my little notebooks that
are like,
you know,
my little that you carry up and I'm
putting on stage with a set list and
then I've got ideas in my phone and then
I've got another bigger notebook with
some more writing in it.
And then I got shit on a computer but
none of it's centralized.
None of it's like an eye.
And I'm like.
But [inaudible] I also think of like,
if I sit down and write a joke,
I then delivered that night.
It doesn't ever feel like how,
I dunno,
I don't.
It just takes work.
If you just try to ride it out the way
you're going to say it on stage,
it will come off clunky but eventually
you'll get it.
But the,
the difference to me is if I just write
in my head and then go on stage and I
have a good premise and I work it out
and it turns into a bit and as long as I
do it a lot,
I memorize it.
That usually does work,
but it's better if I write it out and do
that.
It's better if I do both things.
I still give myself a lot of room on
stage to fuck around and I will just
take a premise and run with it onstage.
But if I have a bit now,
I don't allow myself to not sit in front
of the screen and just write,
write that bit.
Like if there's a bit on,
like I said,
bottled water.
If there's a bit on bottled water,
I will write that bit out and I will
write it again and I'll read it again
and I'll just open up Microsoft word and
start from scratch.
I'll say,
okay,
let's just start that bit over again.
Let's see what it is.
Maybe if I just did it today,
would I do it any differently?
Think you've got to leave that time to
do that.
Yeah,
you have to.
I really feel like there's a lot of
people that say,
oh,
right on stage.
Okay.
I run on stage too,
but I feel like if I write on stage and
I ride in a computer,
it's better.
Yeah.
I feel like my writing's better.
My bits are.
They have more depth to them.
Yeah.
Well you're,
you're taking the time to actually think
about it and then leaving your self that
route.
That's what it is.
It's the time.
It's the time and the focus,
the amount of time thinking about it.
That's what I can't.
That's what I liked.
Especially when I'm on the show.
I'm just like,
that time is not there,
but I'm like,
it's.
You got to decide.
I feel like it's just like whatever
you're doing,
you're going to fucking jump in and do
it or not.
Whatever it is.
Well,
that's one of the reasons I like
podcasts so much because I'm fucking
lazy and you don't have to do anything.
Just show up and start talking like you
and I just talked.
I mean we've already been talking for
fucking two hours.
He just start talking.
Yeah,
that's it.
But it's interesting like people are
happy to have that digests it in this
format right now.
Yeah.
But do you think you could get away with
this onstage?
No.
Yeah,
I mean you could do a podcast on stage
if they knew they were coming to see a
live podcast,
they would enjoy it.
Right.
And people do enjoy it,
but it becomes.
Have you done live podcasts?
Weird.
Right.
It's weird.
Especially if it's like kind of just to
chat,
you know what I mean?
Like if it's like,
yeah,
I feel like I'm ripping these people
off.
I agree.
Unless there's like a specific.
Like we're like I've done my buddy's
podcasts,
like a men's Zucker's,
Paul Scheer and June Raphael have a
podcast.
Like how did this get made where they
talk about shitty movies and then they
like,
they.
Yeah.
And then,
and then you do that live and the
audience has been told what the movie is
and then we get up there and we fuck
around and that feels like everybody.
There's a.
But there is like a pro,
it's not just a pure fuck around,
there's a structure,
there's a structure to it that I feel
like in a live audience loves and
deserves,
like they're psyched about it.
They also know what they're getting in
that case.
But I agree.
Just like us shooting the shit on stage.
It's like people paid real money.
They want to see something that feels
more.
Jeff,
you and I were having this conversation.
There's 2000 people to our right.
It would be very fucking strange.
I'd be like,
sorry,
folks will do.
Is Weird.
Like we're on.
We're seeing this is on youtube right
now.
Yeah.
So yeah.
Hi Guys.
Hi everybody.
Hey.
Hey,
no more than 2000.
But this.
Um,
the thing about being in the presence of
those people is what makes it odd.
Yes,
I agree.
Well that's the same.
It's weirdly kind of what I'm saying
about when we were doing.
Oh hello.
Which is like,
we're not going to acknowledge these
fucking people out there.
You know what I mean?
Let's let them know what we're doing it.
That's the cool thing about that.
You guys wrote it yourself and you don't
have to adhere to,
you know,
there's not a producer that stick to
this ancient script.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's not some like,
uh,
like assistant director come in and be
like,
Hi Mathias.
Thinks that you guys should be,
um,
you noticed that you changed this word.
Like that was what always drove me crazy
was like on set where you're like,
I know.
Especially now where I'm like,
when they wouldn't let you change a
word.
And I'm like,
I get it.
You wrote a great joke.
Absolutely.
But I also know I've been in a writer's
room.
I know that we wrote that joke three
months ago fucking ready for lunch.
Like this isn't some,
this isn't Mozart didn't write some
perfect song that required.
It's like,
you know,
like I respect your process,
but also respect that you wrote this
three months ago and we were not in room
and you were not
with this.
Like we are now in this particular
situation on this day.
So let's also realize that that.
And I accept that when I write for other
people that like whatever I was trying
to do in that room,
let's try to get that.
But let's also acknowledge where we are
in this new moment.
You know?
Yeah.
That was one of the more amazing things
about working with Paul Simms on news
radio is that he allowed you to rewrite
entire scenes.
And I've really.
Yeah.
Dave Foley was really like a secret
producer of that show is Dave Foley is
such a brilliant writer.
What would he would do is like,
there would be a scene that wouldn't
work and he would sit back and be like,
okay,
why does it,
how about it?
Vicky comes in and she introduces this
and then more comes in like here and
then he will,
he will have like a totally different
thing and he'll say,
depaul,
like,
I,
we have a new thing for you.
Tell us what you think.
Paul will go,
love it,
keep it.
And that you guys.
That was in rehearsals leading up to it.
But I think that that's,
to me,
the best creators and see are.
I mean,
I think there are some like,
aw tour geniuses,
but I think for the firm in general,
the best people are the ones who are ego
is enough in check that they can be
like,
I've brought you in to collaborate with
me.
Let's hear what you have to say because
it might be better and it'll make me
equally look good.
Nobody knows.
Nobody knows that it's going to still
say like Paul Simms created the show.
Nobody's going to know that Foley did,
uh,
did,
interesting.
Like rewrite on a rehearsal.
I think Paul would even tell you.
But the thing about it was that when you
write something out,
just like we were talking about before,
if you write jokes,
they don't come to live unless there's
people there.
They come to life when you're actually
performing.
Yeah.
Like a joke just doesn't exist in a
vacuum.
They,
they've really.
You really need an audience.
Yes.
The thing about Ra,
there's a similar process involved in a
sitcom in that as you're running through
it,
then it comes to life and then you
realize the clunky part or you realize a
better way to get to it or you realize,
well this is the joke.
The joke is that he doesn't know this
and that this has happened,
so why don't we have it this way?
And you're like,
ah,
yeah,
we,
I mean,
that's how we,
we do the show,
you know,
we have a fucking killer writer's room.
We will break stories together.
Someone goes off and writes a script,
comes back and then we'll rewrite the
whole script in the room.
And I,
and I,
I don't know if other rooms,
I don't know how other rooms work,
but like we'll read,
we'll read every scene together in the
room just to hear it out loud and then
rewrite it based on like what we all
just laughed at or didn't laugh at.
And so by the time we're actually
getting the table read where we're
hearing it again,
out loud,
even before we get there,
we've read,
we've read it all out loud and put it on
its feet five times before it's even
getting hurt in that,
you know,
what's the grossest
thing of all time?
The fake laugh at the table.
Read the fake writers left as you're
performing,
you feel like a dirty whore and you hear
they're fake laugh.
I know because they're just trying to
sell their show to the networks and the
networks all skeptical.
Hippo face like,
oh this fucking piece of shit.
You guys are selling.
Caught the tail end of the fucking sweet
spot.
Yeah,
the tail end of the Sitcom era.
You really got you guys.
I mean with.
It was a great show.
It's amazing that there's really no
sitcoms anymore.
I mean there was the fucking science
one.
What does that Big Bang theory.
So one last year.
That's amazing.
It's crazy.
That was the first show that I was going
to test for.
Like that was the first like thing that
they were like,
we want to fly to la to test for this.
And I was like,
ah,
I don't think they weren't offering much
money.
They weren't offering a ton of money,
so I was like,
eh.
Even then,
and by the way,
that shows not bad and those guys will
never have to work again ever.
But I just like,
I don't want to be locked into any.
I want to fucking do.
I want to do new stuff.
I want to fuck around.
Yeah.
I just,
my.
We're stuck on that.
Yeah.
And again,
those guys,
God bless him.
Yeah.
How long did you guys do?
Or was it five years,
but it was never a success.
It wasn't.
No,
no,
it bombed every year.
My friend Lou Martin was one of the
know.
Yeah.
He used to wear a t shirt every Monday
of what our ratings were and showed up
on the set one day and it said like 88.
And I went no fucking ways.
That really goes,
Yep,
we're number 88.
I went,
oh my God,
but by the way,
whatever that number was then would now
be a fucking monster hit.
Oh,
the numbers that we would get in in
terms of viewers would be huge.
Yeah,
a huge hit.
Yeah.
In comparison it would be the now will
be dead in the water and now it would be
a huge hit and I'd be psyched,
but then there was the sweet spot then,
which is like between friends and
Seinfeld.
That was the sweet spot and if you could
get into that.
Oh sweet baby.
Jesus,
you are fucking.
You've made it baby.
There was the caroline in the city guy.
Suddenly.
Susan.
Yeah.
They kept trying to these shit what Paul
Simms would call these shit sandwiches.
We have these really good shows that
these slabs are shit and between them
they were fucking terrible,
terrible shows and they went on for a
long time when they were big hits,
but even in syndication there dead like
nobody wants to watch them.
Maybe.
I'm trying to think if I watch news
radio and syndication,
that's probably how you watched it.
It became a hit after the fact.
That was the craziest thing about the
show.
The show became popular after it was
canceled because it was on reruns on
whatever.
Everyone who was attached to so much
controversial because Phil Hartman was
murdered and you know,
before the final season.
Yeah,
it was all so much.
Was that weird?
Crazy.
I mean,
that must have been the saddest,
most tense thing in the world.
That was,
that was
it.
Well,
it taught me a lot.
First of all taught me do not stay in
one of those evil relationships because
there's people that just,
they just don't work together and they
try to make it work together and you
went to fucking hating each other and
that was him and her.
It was ugly and I tried to get him to
divorce her several times and he was
terrified of losing his image.
Terrified of losing money.
I mean,
he just didn't want to be a divorced
Hollywood bachelor guy.
His image was the family guy,
you know,
I'm a married man,
family guy.
Everything's great.
Everything about him is like,
I look like a nice man.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly the funniest,
but he was living in hell.
It was awful.
Yeah.
She would like openly insulting him at
parties and stuff and we would just
cringe like toxic.
She hated him,
you know,
and she wound up shooting him in his
sleep.
I mean it was,
it was so intense.
As ugly as it gets.
I mean he took like a Nyquil or
something like that to go to sleep and
she shot him in the head while he was
sleeping.
She had.
How did you guys find out on like a next
day or like how do I.
well,
I found out,
I think I got a phone call.
Yeah,
that's what it was.
I got a phone call.
This is like pre,
pre cell phone.
Pre email probably.
Yeah,
it was 90.
I want to say 98.
I guess I had a phone but I mean I guess
I had a cell phone,
had a shitty Motorola startac.
Remember those razor they are not having
there.
Yeah,
about 47 minutes of talk time out of
battery.
But uh,
yeah,
actually now that I remember I found
about it to,
this is crazy.
I found out about it from a girl I'd
gone on a date with who worked for like
one of those shows like hard copies that
she called me up and she was trying to
send a news crew to my house.
What a nice.
What a nice person.
It's like,
what the fuck are you talking about to
interview you?
We're going to send a crew to your house
or what?
And then um,
and then,
uh,
tuned in the news and there was hell,
this is what.
It was really weird.
There was helicopters flying over
Steve's of Phil's house.
And then there was that guy who was in a
cocoon who was like a really famous
actor for awhile,
but he lost his fucking marbles.
Who is that guy that was in a cocoon the
young.
He was a young,
handsome guy.
Steve Gutenberg know that his name.
I mean the Gutenberg press was him.
Yeah.
That guy lost his mind.
He lost his mind and he,
um,
his career had fallen apart.
So he had pulled up a photo of Steve
Gutenberg.
Let me make sure it's him for.
Yeah,
let me see what is that,
what it looks like now,
but back then?
Yes.
So see if you can Google Steve
Gutenberg.
I'm at Phil Hartman's murder because he
had decided that he was going to talk
for a,
to the,
to the police,
talked to CNN.
Yeah.
Or not to.
He was going to talk to the press.
So he put on like a suit and he got out
there and he was,
he was out there talking to,
uh,
to the press and we were all like,
what the fuck is he doing?
I mean maybe he's fucking,
you don't hear about this guy anymore.
Right?
He kind of vanished,
but he had already vanished back then.
It had already.
It was already like
post all those movies most to the police
academy and all that Shit.
And there's a weird thing that happens
to some of these guys where they just
like,
it's all gone,
right?
And then they're like,
oh,
this is an opportunity for me to get
back on camera.
And we were all,
all of us were like,
how well did he know Steve Gutenberg?
Like,
what the fuck is going on?
It was the strangest thing.
Him standing there with a suit on,
talking to all the press and talking to
people.
It was so weird.
I mean maybe I'm wrong and maybe he did
have this wonderful relationship that
Phil never talked about,
but I was pretty close to fill.
But I mean,
I don't know.
I think there's a certain,
there's a certain weirdness to talking
to the press about someone who's just
been murdered and people that are
willing to like go on camera and give
interviews and stuff.
It's like,
are you morning?
Aren't you freaked out?
Like aren't you,
I,
I just was.
This is a slightly changed.
But it was so.
It was like.
Do you remember where you were when the
Oj verdict was written?
I was in high school.
I climbed a tree pledget climate trail
that other people be like,
where were you when the Oj verdict in a
tree?
Remember I was with my girlfriend at the
time and she threw her hands on her
face.
And went.
Oh No.
She's kept saying.
Oh really?
She just went.
Oh.
Oh No.
Are you in la?
Yeah,
we were watching it in my apartment.
We were watching the verdict and w and I
was dumbfounded.
I thought it was going to jail.
Everybody thought he was going to jail
and she just,
she just kept going.
Oh No.
Yeah,
I just remember being in high school.
I knew Ron Goldman sister to really?
Yeah.
That was real weird.
I knew his sister
and because also like her,
her Ron Goldman's father and I have no,
like,
I can't imagine.
I can't even begin to fathom what that
whole experience would be for anyone.
But he was like,
he felt very performative to me.
Like he felt like he,
like he was.
Again,
I say this with all due respect,
like I don't know what it's,
I have,
would have no sense of what that
experience is like.
But there are certain people that are
like,
oh,
you do like being on camera.
I know something horrible happened to
you,
but you did like being on camera.
I mean,
I have no idea.
Yeah,
I don't know either.
I mean,
who the fuck,
how you know,
how I would react.
Your son was murdered by some superstar.
Like just think about how crazy that is.
Not just murdered but murdered by a
famous guy who then is like on off
flaunted and got off.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
He was a part of this weird race thing
where it was post Rodney King.
So there was a lot of people that felt
like there was some sort of a racist
aspect to it that like there was a
racist cops who got off with Rodney
King,
so now it's their chance to get one for
black folks and talk to people about it,
you know,
it's that cray.
Did you watch the,
you do watch the Oj,
the documentary.
And then also there was the fx show
watch one episode of the Fx show and I
was like,
Damn.
Cuba gooding Jr and fucking nailed it.
He really seemed like Oj in it.
It was really good.
Yeah.
But that's all.
Well,
the documentary is interesting because
it sets up like la all like that.
The preceding years leading up to posts,
riots,
all that stuff like and you're like,
oh,
it does.
It sort of.
It does like lend itself to be like,
oh,
this was,
this was a perfect confluence of events
that led to this thing of like,
you know,
racial up,
all,
everything that went into the Oj trial.
It's fucking nuts.
It's crazy.
It was a,
a strange,
strange time.
It was a strange time because it just
seemed like the world was made of
something that was way more flexible
than I ever thought it was before.
Like I never thought Oj Simpson could be
a murderer.
I thought murderers were bad people and
that the people that you thought of,
that we're good people on tv,
you would never think of like Oj was
always so friendly and smiley and he
would have that big laugh and he is
handsome.
Talk about head injuries to cte.
It's like you're like,
oh,
I wonder what?
Oh,
for sure.
Or had to do with it.
Yeah.
One hundred percent,
1000 million percent.
In fact,
his doctor said that if the trial were
to take place today,
is Dr the time they would introduce ct?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Can you see all those students?
I mean like the,
the level of violence that there is
here.
Yes,
that's right.
Police Academy.
He's funny in naked gun,
but it's interesting.
You go back and watch that documentary
and it's like,
you know,
his buddies,
his like his good buddies who stood by
him,
his good buddies who stood by him
talking about him in high school and
he's Kinda like he was fucking thrown
his friends under the bus in school.
Like the,
all three of them would be like doing
some like in the bathroom,
like doing some shit.
They're supposed to be in class and the
principal would come in and the three of
them were all together and Oj would
saddle up next to the principal and be
like,
what are we going to do with these two
guys?
You know what I mean?
He was like throwing his buddies under
the bus.
You're like,
oh,
he was CD fucked him up.
I don't know what kind of man he would
have been like,
whether he would have been so violent or
whatever,
but you're like piece of shit plus it
kind of felt like he was a piece of shit
his whole life.
Well,
how about the book?
If I did it,
how crazy.
How crazy is that?
That he wrote a book?
If I do,
I do identify.
Did you see that?
Did you ever say.
Have you ever seen his prank show?
Juiced?
Oh yes.
That's post the murder.
Oh yeah.
Post the murder.
Man.
It's fucking crazy.
Do you ever see his rap song?
No.
Oh,
young.
Jamie.
Find it again.
Oh yes,
yes.
This was part of that juiced I think
thing,
right?
It's in that same thing and it's part of
Jen's.
It's like,
and it's all these young.
It's all these like little hottie Yang,
a little hotties we look like,
like Nicole,
it's so far.
What does that picture of him with the
glasses that's from one of the sketches.
Look at that crazy one in the fuck is
that boy.
He can go anywhere with that.
You can go to Disneyland here that
famous and you did something awful like
that.
You gotta go in disguise.
How many chicks bang him?
Just because he's Oj now?
A lot.
You think still people.
Are you still thinking we're going to
bang him?
Yes.
One hundred percent.
I know Jay pretended he would.
What?
What does it say it?
This guy tried to hold this guy.
Oh God.
The poor guy.
Imagine mailman.
I wonder 100 percent.
Yeah.
There's Wacky broads that want to bang
murderers.
Really?
Yes.
I buy.
Yeah,
I guess so.
There's,
there's a guy that we had in here,
Nikki Harris,
who uh,
went to jail.
He was on death row for 20 years for a
crime that 22 years for a crime they
didn't commit and he said since getting
out,
he's just in it.
He was asking on the podcast with these
women to stop sending him emails.
Um,
I'm married.
I have a good relationship.
Like please leave me alone.
Like stop testing me.
And like,
really?
Yeah.
They just throw that buzzy.
Interesting.
Yeah.
There's a Richard Ramirez,
the night stalker,
that guy apparently got all these women
were sending him pictures and email or
letters and he might have married some
woman.
Really?
Manson's Manson got married.
Yeah.
A lot of them get married.
Real common.
Fuck man.
Crazy.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
I'd fuck Oj.
I would too.
I'd fucking with you.
We'd high five each other.
Would you want the front of the back?
I wouldn't want.
I don't think I'd want the front.
I think I probably more dangerous.
We had a cte like flashback and pick
your deck off.
Oh,
that's true.
You could control.
You can control the back a little bit.
Yeah.
I wonder what his teeth did in prison.
He's out now,
right?
Nobody's out.
Yeah.
Which is really weird.
That's wild.
What is Oj doing these days?
He was,
I can't remember.
What he was doing recently is Jamie.
It's got a good podcast.
I've done his podcast.
I put on my,
um,
my twitter.
Should I interview Oj on my podcast or
not?
What was,
what was the response?
Moshe Kasher just sent me a text versus
like,
what the fuck would you.
I guess that would legitimize or my
guests and what an interview with that.
Legitimize him.
I've heard that before.
Oj Simpson living life of luxury in
Vegas.
Twenty three years.
What year is this?
This was 18.
Oh,
this is just now last week.
Wow.
He's living a life of luxury in Vegas.
Look at him just walking around.
Strolling plays golf four to five times
a week and the exclusive,
a royal golf club.
Far from keeping a low profile.
The form of Buffalo Bill Star has been
spotted and hotels and even a Vegas
Golden Knights hockey game.
Wow.
What the fuck?
Look at him.
Look at it again.
Someone young poster.
Look at that girl.
O Lmg people.
Fuck him.
I guarantee you girls.
One hundred percent.
I wonder probably more than us combined.
The Chelsea Hotel Breathalyzer sensor
reported travels around town with his
own breathalyzer.
If he exceeds a certain blood alcohol
level,
he could be sent back to prison,
so maybe he should just stop drinking.
Maybe it should just stop.
She enjoys a Martini a day,
but what does that.
If he what?
What is the blood alcohol level?
They're sending you back to prison.
How crazy is that?
It's free,
but if you have three beers,
you're fucking shit.
He's on parole I guess.
Right?
He was anally or the thing that's Colin
did.
He is at the very end of it.
He was trying to talk him into saying
that he did it.
Yeah.
I think he was.
Oh,
J was more aware of what was going on.
Then a bunch of the other people on that
show.
Well,
I mean you'd think he's probably a hyper
paranoid that someone's fucking with
him.
Fuck everybody's fucking.
Since always look up more young pussy
for Oj.
Oj wanted to meet me.
My name is Nicole.
He said that's his favorite name.
Oh my God.
That is insane.
But you know what?
I bet he gets a lot of those vacant odd
young ladies to accept his penis.
I have trouble believing that.
Maybe.
I mean,
why?
Because you think.
Do you ever.
Do you ever ironically fuck somebody.
Some gals would do that,
right?
Ironically,
fucking murder.
I guess further can't imagine I maybe,
I can't imagine.
I don't know what the social like the
currency of that is.
What Scott Peterson was sent to death
row in California,
San Quentin prison for murdering his
wife and their unborn child.
Dozens of women phoned asking for his
address with one teenager wasting no
time and offering to marry him.
Wow.
Yeah.
There's A.
I think this is what I think.
I think there is some sort of ancient
DNA that people have that attracts them
to murderers and conquerors because
those are the people that survived and
the your some sort of a strange
inclination for some women,
obviously ones that are not thinking
clearly,
but for some women to want the sperm and
the genetics of a murderer because
that's the type of the.
If you add a murderous,
brave conqueror for a child,
that child would survive like that DNA.
Yeah.
I mean I get some sense of survival.
I mean in at times of barbaric.
Sure,
sure.
You want it to be with someone.
Yeah.
That's what I think it is like a killer.
So much like the caveman comedian.
Well,
I think that if a male feminist goes to
jail,
they get zero request for marriage.
They get none.
But uh,
yeah.
If some male feminist like gets arrested
and goes to jail,
it's a wrap.
Yeah,
that's it.
But if you're a murder murder,
you'd probably get a lot because women,
there's a reason why men become.
I mean there's,
there's men who believe in equality and
women's rights and then there's men who
are really weasley and what they're
doing is they just,
they're young and posturing and I think
those guys,
if they go to jail,
crickets.
Well,
either way they're in,
they're in jail so they're not.
They're probably not.
I don't know how it works.
I don't know to get places you can get
conjugal visits,
but I think it's dependent upon the
jail.
You didn't cosby's getting any marital,
any proposals?
I bet he does.
I bet girls and trying to get raped by
him,
believe it or not.
I bet there are some girls who would
want caused me to drug them because
people are fucking crazy.
People get their faces tattooed.
People,
you know,
there's people that are just straight up
nuts.
Yeah.
And when there's a high profile thing
like that.
Yeah.
I think.
I think when I think about that,
I'm like,
what happened to those people that made
them to the point where they would be
interested in something like that?
The person that goes after.
Yeah.
I have my theories about cosby.
I think that when that happened,
when cosby first started doing that,
I think it was common.
I think that whole slipping manish fly
shit.
Dash fly.
Yeah.
I think in the sixties and the fifties,
I think asshole men did that to women
all the fucking time and I don't think
people thought about the consequences
and don't think people thought about the
rights of women.
I mean if you just think about like
chauvinism in films,
male,
Male,
chauvinist behavior and sexist behavior.
Men smacking women in films.
I mean it was really common.
Steve Mcqueen and Allie what it was when
the alley sheedy,
Allie McGraw,
Allie McGraw beat the fuck out of her in
a scene,
like an actual scene and she didn't even
know he was going to do it.
Just beat the shit out of her and the
look on film.
Right.
That was the thing that just came out.
It was like Brando was like,
oh we didn't.
We just sprung this sexual encounter on
this woman.
Yeah.
That different game.
It was a different world and I think
there was a lot of.
I mean he was always hanging around at
the playboy mansion.
I think there was a lot of men that just
raped women and drug them.
I think it was common.
I'm sure you've talked to many women
that have had something dropped in their
drink,
right?
Yeah,
for sure.
Crazy.
There's darkness out there.
So much darkness out there and it's a
bummer.
It's such a fucking bummer man.
It's such a bummer.
And it's.
Yeah,
it's a and you think about but with it's
crazy with cosby is like,
it was an until again,
it's.
I mean,
it's crazy to think now however many
years ago,
Hannibal sending onstage,
like we all knew some version,
like we'd all heard some stories about
cosby and it's just sort of like,
oh well bill's bill,
I heard about it on the set of news
radio.
That's when I heard it.
Fuck yeah.
And nobody's going to touch him.
Well,
no one knew for sure.
Nobody knew to the extent I guess or
heard you had heard from someone that,
you know.
The crazy thing is when Hannibal said
that on stage,
the people that aren't connected to
Hollywood were like,
wait,
what?
Yeah,
what the fuck to say he's a rapist.
Like that video went viral.
Millions of people saw it and I like
what bill cosby rapes people and then
everyone's like,
but like he raped me and what?
It's crazy and now he's in jail.
It's darkness.
Good fucking good man.
Well it's crazy.
I'm good.
But crazy that it took so long and
crazy.
That was only for three years.
He's got a three year,
sent three to 10 year sentence,
which is,
that's the last one they could get them
for.
Right,
right.
But I mean,
do you ever see him live?
Did you ever burn?
And I were supposed to go for all that
shit went down and um,
we wound up canceling and then burn
wound up seeing him and he said it was
amazing.
Chris Rock said he was fucking amazing
to Chris Rock said that he felt like he
was an amateur after you watched cause
he said,
yeah.
He goes,
I felt like I don't know what the fuck
I'm doing.
Yeah,
I saw him once in Montreal during the
festival.
I was hung over and I watched and I fell
asleep.
It was like a Sunday afternoon.
I was like,
I'll sit down and tell her your story.
Weird.
If you really enjoyed it.
If he was your best,
your favorite comedian.
I know that would suck.
Would suck.
It would suck more.
Who is your favorite standup when you,
when you were first starting?
Uh,
well,
let's see.
When I first started,
I started in New York sort of a moment.
The alt scene like I remember seeing
Galifianakis early on and being like,
Jesus Christ,
what the fuck is this guy know he.
He does so good.
Yeah.
He'll pop up and be any so funny.
I remember seeing bur because I had been
doing sort of more alt room stuff and
then I remember seeing her come to like
a,
like the UCB in New York and seeing him,
you stand up and be like,
oh,
he's doing him and he's doing it in this
space where people are not used to
seeing just a straight standup and he's
fucking killing.
I remember seeing him earlier on being
like,
Jesus,
this guy is fucking killing.
And,
and being like very impressed me.
Like how do I do that?
And however many years later I'm still
like,
how do I do that?
When you were a kid,
was there anyone really stood out to
you?
Consider Standard.
I mean I remember seeing delirious,
watching delirious and then being like
the specials that I had around me
growing up where Carlin and Carnegie
delirious and like Robin Williams at the
met or something or like those specials.
Those are big for me and I just remember
seeing delirious and being like
memorizing though.
Did you ever get to meet Robin?
No.
Did you see them at the store?
A bunch or like around.
I met.
I met him in the craziest way possible.
I did a set at the Improv and afterwards
I was taking pictures with people.
There was like a line of people and I
was taking photos and this old guy with
his white beard and glasses and a
baseball hat came up and he wanted to
tell me how funny thought the show was
and I was talking to him for a couple
minutes before I realized it was Robin
Williams.
She's and then in the middle of it like
we're talking.
Oh,
thank you.
That's so nice.
I really,
I really appreciate it man.
Thanks.
I'm glad you enjoyed it.
Holy Shit.
I never told them.
I knew I was like,
but my brain saying I didn't know what
to say.
I really appreciate that.
Thank you so much.
You know,
and,
and you know,
he was just talking about a specific bit
that I was doing and you know,
like about how crazy it was and like I
love the twist in the turn and this and
then I was like,
wow,
thanks man.
The guy waited in line with everybody.
That's why I just waited in line,
came by himself.
Did you see him doing some version of
your bit?
Couple of days.
He would.
Recipes,
recipes.
You know what you did.
Thankfully he wasn't doing standup back
then.
That was a,
when he was doing that show,
remember he was doing that show,
the crazy ones.
Oh yeah,
back and tried to do a sitcom before he.
Yeah.
But he,
yeah,
I mean I had friends.
Everyone would see him in like he'd
come,
he'd come to do Improv at ucb or,
and then he would go and do you know,
he was sort of,
I don't know if he was doing stand up at
any point,
but you know,
I never got to catch.
I never got my like,
you know,
I have a lot of friends who I feel like
got,
got a little touch from him and,
and that feeling of like you are,
you know,
I mean because he was a guy who I was
like,
oh,
that's what I like.
You're doing what I like,
you're doing standup but it's characters
and you're doing all this stuff and
you're acting and you get to be in
serious movies and you get to be in
common.
Like I was sort of like,
he was sort of sort of a model of like,
well,
I was like,
I think I would like to do what he's
doing.
Yeah.
He was so flexible in what he was able
to do.
Yeah.
Did you ever see patch adams?
No.
It might be the worst movie ever made
worse.
It's probably right up there with the
Travolta Gotti movie,
but it helps.
Yeah.
I don't want to see that Travolta guy
today on the elliptical.
You fucking city.
Every exec.
He says,
fuck every three words and you're like,
oh,
johnny,
look at you.
This fucking city I fucking logo.
It looks so bad.
I love though.
There is something
that I like.
I just like love the John Travolta
patrol to that.
There's so many.
I like love about a man so deeply out of
touch.
I mean that's the thing is like,
yeah,
look it up.
Fucking thumbs fucking up.
Me and my wife's Jewish,
just Sarah Palin and I love this fucking
city boy.
The,
the sexual chemistry between them is
palpable.
Probably Real,
super rude.
You were talking about at the beginning
of like cults and I'm like,
I'm thinking about.
I'm thinking about Tom Cruise and
scientology.
There is a man using every ounce of what
scientology's offering to make himself
the best available man that he's capable
of being.
Then you've got Travolta.
You know what I mean?
Like you've got two versions of like
Amanda who's becoming slightly out of
touch with what he,
you know,
hey look at my fucking wig.
It's a good way.
How amazing our wigs these days got
great wigs.
I mean that's a fucking incredible wig.
Thinning.
Just a little bit upfront.
You would think that's his hair.
He's living the dream.
It's incredible.
He's living in a goddamn dream.
Are you okay with time we can wrap this
up or whatever?
Yeah.
I'm 30 3:30.
Where?
Where does that appear?
On the Oj thing.
Oh yeah,
that was.
I saw him.
That's amazing.
That little.
That little chin.
Is that his.
He wore a little chin.
Chin Yamaka there.
It's unbelievable.
I remember seeing him at an award
ceremony that and then when he had that
little Chin thing and I was like,
did he put that on after the thing?
I met him when his wife was on fear
factor.
Really?
Yeah.
Kelly Preston was unfair.
She was on fear factor.
Celebrity fear factor.
David Hasselhoff.
Kelly.
Wow.
Preston.
How were they?
She was really nice.
She was super friendly,
but I felt like I felt like they
recruited people.
Yes.
Yeah.
I mean they were there for.
Scientology was sort of a stigmatized.
It was.
There was a lot of people that were
joining it.
What is going on there,
let's say as a black cap.
I love it out here is so crazy.
Fake looking.
That's like that magnetic man that you
could like move the magnets around the
created hair.
[inaudible]
hair looks like that.
That's crazy,
man.
That's the color.
Everything is wrong.
That's madness.
Um,
but yeah,
she was super friendly.
She was really down earth.
Super Normal and friendly.
She's like,
these trenches are great and you know,
if you eat enough and you want to come
and hang out later,
we could eat more.
Yes,
we could maximize eating.
Sure.
Angela's and you can join,
you can jump.
We can Olympic get your phone number.
Come from brunch.
He meters.
Yeah.
I remember watching that go and clear
the documentary and being like,
Oh,
I'm not scared.
Like they're not coming for me.
Like Ms Dot Kovich is not coming from
me.
He's coming for the people under him who
he sees as a threat.
Like I don't think he sees us as a
threat.
Like I don't think he gives a fuck.
Us being like,
ah,
I don't know about scientology.
He shields himself from anything like
this.
Any kind of criticism and.
Yeah.
But I do tell you that I had miscavige
has data on.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh right,
because he's the,
he's,
he left.
Yeah,
he fucking escape.
But that's what I'm saying.
Like if dad,
I'm scared because he's like Mrs.
which is like my dad is a threat to me.
Like you and I talking about
scientology.
I don't think ms.dot.
She gives a fuck.
It was a weird conversation.
What was he like?
Well,
he sad is he lost his whole life to this
nonsense and the sun's gone.
Like he can't.
His son won't contact them.
And it was his idea to get the family
and the.
He filled the guilt of that.
Yeah.
The Sun rises through the ranks,
winds up running the whole fucking thing
and that was something won't talk to
them.
My favorite thing is miscavige and Tom
Cruise.
Shaking hands.
Yes.
It's the best.
It's like this.
It's this.
It's this tiny alpha men.
Men miscavige is trumping him where you
can,
you can see Tom cruise trying to pull
his hand away and Ms Dot,
which is like,
I will not relent.
I will not release.
And you can see Tom,
Chris being like this Tinier man than me
has an even higher level of Alphas than
I on.
And I will,
I will relent.
Well the real threat to them as Leah
Remini mean.
What Leah Remini,
he's done like she is looking at it.
You can see him trying to pull this
fucking salute.
They salute,
salute.
And then hand Tom Cruise like trying to
pull his hand away and miscavige won't
let it go.
It's really fantastic planting.
Yeah.
Unrelenting.
You can see it's trying to like,
you can see the hands turn to like come
loose and he won't let it happen.
He's like,
and it's like that trump move.
My favorite thing is when they salute
the,
the picture of Lrh,
they saluted a shitty science fiction
writer looking at.
He was wearing that big dinner plate
around his neck.
They know and look at it is not a tall
man.
And miscavige is he towers over Tom
Cruise.
Tom Cruise over.
Sorry.
Yes.
Yeah.
Look at that fucking giant gold medal he
wants by being the most awesome person
in the universe.
But again,
I'm like,
I don't know.
Did you see the recent mission?
Impossible.
He's amazing.
It's amazing.
He's a fucking fantastic and I'm like so
onboard.
I'm onboard for the whole thing.
I'm like,
listen man,
you know how hard it is to get a movie
made now to get anybody to pay
attention.
Go learn to fucking flight helicopter
and jump off a building and break your
ankle.
Like fucking go for it,
man.
Well,
you know as well as I do.
You've been around a lot of actors.
They're all fucking crazy,
but his crazy.
It's just a different kind of crazy,
but it's also a different kind of
success.
Yeah,
but I'm like,
he's a guy who I feel like you would get
like,
like he's like,
yeah,
like whatever I need to do.
Like I will.
I will maximize myself the gold medal.
It's fucking amazing.
I love it.
I get some volume.
Let me hear some of this.
I take this as a halfback,
some inside joke that's like a good
insights.
I tagged you.
I will continue on my way.
These are the times now people.
Okay.
These are the times we will all
remember,
isn't that the song?
Were you there?
What did you do?
I think you know that I am there for
you.
Hmm.
And I do care so very,
very,
very much.
That's why he's the best actor ever.
You're full of Shit right there.
And we'll leave it.
Or do you think he's full of Shit?
I feel like he's on the verge of tears.
I think he but he,
he's full shift for sure.
With everything he does.
I don't think there's a moment in his
life where he's not full of shit.
Right?
But he's believes it's so deep.
Please look at this.
The solute.
Go back up,
back up a little bit.
I need to see that again.
Watch this dweller age.
Anything about
that guy l Ron Hubbard was a fucking
maniac.
Did you read going clear?
Did you just see the digest size?
Documentary book is fucking fantastic.
The book is.
He was fucking shit.
House rat.
Crazy.
Crazy on a boat.
Oh Jeez.
He was out of his fucking mind himself.
A bunch of metals.
Have you seen that?
There's a,
uh,
there's a podcast called,
you must remember this and it's like all
about old Hollywood.
And it somehow circumvents a little bit
of like l Ron Hubbard seen in like
Pasadena with like all these other like,
you know,
spiritualists futurists are like.
And then it's like,
it's Cuckoos Ville.
They are,
they are,
they are cruising on their own fucking
agenda and it's kind of amazing.
But he's,
yeah,
it was,
I wish I had more information and put
again in my brain doesn't retain the
stuff I need to get it into scientology.
The books help if you just maximize your
eat or whatever you fucking.
Do you ever do a stress test?
Do you ever go again?
One,
one time I was filming a television show
in San Diego and we had downtime when
they were setting up a scene and we
happened to be at a park where they had
one of those scientology booths set up
and I went over there and the guy put me
through the whole thing.
I hold onto the cans and they're
connected to the wires,
but he was so unenthusiastic he wasn't
selling it at all outside ties.
I don't know,
something in your past,
the tetons or.
I don't know,
man.
The guy had no energy for,
it was hilarious.
Worst salesman,
I think they just make them do it,
you know,
and some people don't want to do it and
next thing you know they've got a
fucking conference table set up in a
park and the stack of books and they're
going nowhere
in clear water.
Didn't no where near clearwater.
They were on the other coast.
I got to get to the fucking east coast,
goddammit man.
God bless him though.
I,
I am like,
I am weirdly like,
I mean I don't know about goblets,
like dislocating people disconnect
people from their families,
but I am like,
I am sort of have the feeling like
whatever you,
if you can find something for yourself
that brings you some answers and,
and like gives you some comfort and
motivates you to be the best person you
can be.
I'm like,
yeah,
good,
good.
Do whatever the fuck you want.
I don't give a shit.
I agree.
I do.
I am like,
if you're like dislocating people from
their families and stealing everybody's
money,
like whatever,
but whatever your personal choices.
I'm like,
go for it man.
I don't give a shit and quite honestly
like,
why is it okay,
okay to be a Catholic and it's not okay
to be a scientologist because Catholic
Catholicism,
which I grew up with,
is one of the fucking nuttiest religions
filled with kid fuckers where they
literally have their own country,
the Vatican's,
its own country.
They move priests around all over the
world.
It happened.
There was a new case.
It just happened a couple of weeks ago
in Pennsylvania.
They just found thousands of children
that had been molested.
Yeah,
no,
it's systematic.
It's crazy.
When did you.
Was there a moment in the church where
you're like,
oh,
I'm out.
I'm done.
Well,
I was really lucky
without my parents split up in.
When my parents split up.
I went to Catholic school for one year
after that and then my mom met my
Stepdad who was a hippie and he was
like,
this is fucking stupid,
and the next thing you know,
we moved to San Francisco,
so we were in New Jersey.
I was going to Catholic school a year
later,
living in San Francisco next to gay
people and living right off of,
um,
what's that?
Lombard street cricket,
a street in the world down near
Fisherman's wharf.
So that's a change.
This is the craziest shift.
I mean this was also during the Vietnam
war,
so I went from being in this really sort
of repressive east coast Italian
Catholic environment to being around
nothing but hippies and gay people out.
Your mom wanted out?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Everybody wanted out.
My stepdad wanted out,
my mom wanted out.
They realized that there was also.
This was 1971.
I was seven,
so it was 73,
74,
74.
So it was like the heat of the Vietnam
War.
The hippie movement was in full swing.
Nixon I think was president.
It was craziness back then and fuck,
everybody wanted out,
you know?
Yeah.
Have you listened to that?
There's a podcast called slow burn who
listened to see that it's all about
Watergate and it sort of from the angle
of like how it just took awhile to
unfold.
Like it just like you're like,
oh,
okay.
Took it like this didn't happen
overnight because they were like the
Russia trump investigation.
Yeah.
It's like the slow,
just like it's just slowly unfolding
piece by piece and you're like,
uh,
overtime you're like,
oh,
right,
like these dominoes slowly fall.
And
in that one you're like,
I didn't,
I just didn't know that much about
Watergate,
but I was like,
oh,
like the water could happen.
And the election was five months later
and Nixon won in a landslide.
Like the country was like,
the country was like,
eh.
Watergate said it's not that,
it's nothing big deal.
And then it was another year,
year and a half before,
like he finally,
before he was impeached,
he took a while.
I did not know that.
Yeah,
it's kind of,
it's kind of crazy,
but it gets like,
it gets into some of the early stuff of
like Watergate and after Watergate and
all the,
like sort of the beginning of what I
think became like legit legitimizing and
different versions of like conspiracy
theories.
I was like,
what's really going on here?
Should,
you know?
And it's,
it's pretty,
it's 74 and he resigned,
but he was reelected.
Yeah,
he was reelected.
Watergate had happened.
Nobody had nobody thought about it after
his resignation was issued.
A controversial pardon by success.
That's exactly what Mike Pence is going
to do.
Fuck.
You think you'll go down and you think
he'll get impeached?
I don't know.
I just thought that more a few months
ago now.
It feels like I just,
he's so preposterous that as time rolls
on where we're conditioned to his
preposterousness just all of it loses
its teeth.
Look,
I mean the stormy Daniels thing,
nobody gives a fuck about it anymore.
Like,
yeah,
I fucked her.
So what?
But I feel like,
yeah,
I feel like they,
everybody knew he was fucking people
before.
It's like,
it's,
if you don't apply yourself to a,
a normal moral framework,
then it's not like he was um,
super ethical guy.
Like who was the guy that was running
for president?
And it turned out that he was chief John
Edwards.
Yes.
While she was dying of cancer,
right?
Yeah.
And he's having an affair or a baby with
someone.
Yeah.
And that's cook.
Well that's the problem with like when
you see like Al Franken go down for
like,
you know,
nothing,
nothing.
And it's because on that side it's like,
it,
it's like the moral framework is like,
you can't do that to women,
but if you're,
if you're,
if,
if you're a trump guy,
then you're like,
it's not if you're a trump guy.
But it's like,
it's like,
yeah,
well that's how Donald is,
right?
Like,
and he's like,
that's how I am.
Yeah.
So if below Riley was taking pictures of
the chicken grab there,
but everybody would go,
yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
But it's like,
if it's on the other side,
it's like,
well there's a moral framework there
that you're like,
fuck,
we got to.
If we're going to say that that's the
deal.
Then we have to follow through that.
That's the deal.
Michael event.
It was going to have a naughty naughty.
Yeah.
This guy was running,
he was the,
the,
this would be great for two coasts
proposing a three round mixed martial
arts fight with Donald Trump jr for
charity.
No joke.
And Michael Avanav,
he said this will be for two great
causes.
I'm in what?
This guy.
He's just,
he likes to play tennis.
Yeah,
he loves it a little too much.
He's a little.
They were trying to get some show with
him in the MOOC.
Right?
What's his name?
Carmen SCARAMUCCI.
He wants to run for president of Anohni.
He'll be the big threat and 20,
22 the Democrats.
I can't,
I can't imagine that he's supposedly
getting released from jail soon.
Wiener on good behavior.
How is he still in jail?
What did he do?
The sexual with a kid or something like
that.
Texting with the kids.
That what it was.
That's what I got to know for that
smooth chest.
Okay.
And on that note,
let's wrap this up.
What do you got going on?
Anything people need to know about?
Fuck A.
Yeah,
big mouse.
He's in twos out now on Netflix.
Hilarious fucking show.
Thanks man.
Thank you.
One of the best animated shows ever.
Thanks man.
I appreciate it.
Uh,
yeah,
I guess that's really it.
I mean,
that's,
that's the one I have is my
autobiography that I've poured my life
into it.
So I guess that's the thing.
That would be the thing.
You should promote it.
And you do insets at the store.
We went together the other night to the
store.
I do a show at Largo,
a monthly semi monthly.
I'll actually wanted to talk to,
about coming and doing the show at
Largo.
Yeah.
Um,
I do that Nick Kroll and friends and
then,
uh,
yeah,
I got other shit coming down,
but it's a big mouth.
Big Mouth.
Netflix.
Go Watch it.
Thanks.
Bye.
Sure.